foreign
do you want to engage the power of cloud
computing and a mark on a journey to
digital transformation cloud computing
Basics is your gateway to harnessing the
immense potential of this Cutting Edge
technology by leveraging the cloud you
will Propel your business to new heights
of efficiency scalability and Innovation
cloud computing isn't just a buzzword
it's a game changer with a seamless
blend of flexibility and cost
Effectiveness the cloud revolutionizes
The Way businesses operate say goodbye
to Hefty infrastructure costs and hello
to unlimited storage on demand resources
and lightning fast processing speeds
did you know that by 2023 the global
public Cloud Market is projected to
exceed a staggering 800 billion dollars
that's right the demand for cloud
services is chirocative and the
opportunities are Limitless for those
with the right skills but cloud
computing is more than just numbers it's
a gateway to Endless Possibilities from
startups to multinational corporations
organizations of all sizes are embracing
the cloud to accelerate their digital
transformation Journey streamline
operations and enhance customer
experiences
now let's talk about the figures that
matters cloud computing professionals
are earning top dollar salaries with
entry-level positions commanding an
impressive range of sixty thousand
dollars to hundred thousand dollars per
year as you gain expertise and
experience you can unlock even more
lucrative opportunities in this rapidly
expanding field
so if you are ready to embark on this
exciting career path look no further
than simply learn skal Tech postgraduate
program in cloud computing this
comprehensive program will equip you
with the knowledge and skills needed to
navigate the cloud landscape with
confidence dive deep into Cloud
architecture deployment models security
and migration strategies explore
platforms like Amazon web services
Microsoft Azure and Google Cloud
platform to build your Cloud expertise
don't miss out on this chance to
transform your career and join the ranks
of successful Cloud professionals click
the link in the description box below to
discover more about the cloud computing
Basics course to know more about this
course click on the link mentioned in
the description box below here inspiring
success stories from A Satisfied
Learners who have unlocked the full
potential of cloud computing
I will be permanently moving to Europe
with my family so simply learn this
course has helped me back a great job
offered there will be the 60 salary high
we cannot wait to start our new life in
Finland we are also excited hey I am
and I am currently living in Algeria I
am working as Chief Information
Technology officer at aristiles after
working for 23 years in I.T sector in
Algeria I felt that my career had become
stagnant here I wanted to experience
what is like to live in Europe so I
started applying to various jobs there
as someone who is responsible for making
the decision I wanted to upgrade my
skills I also realized that to get a new
job I needed to have a personal
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing in association with
Caltech concept radio it's not easy to
get access to Caltech but simply didn't
provided that with this course I had the
choice to study while I can tune it with
my job
either Technologies like ews and Azure
during the course luckily my new
employers were looking for someone who
knew these Technologies I have just
copulated the course but my new
employers were aware that I was taking
this course
and that is how I got this new job offer
with 60 percent salary high in Finland I
will be leading the cloud computing unit
of my new company
I am really excited not just for myself
but for my family as well I have 30
dollars I think I will be able to help
them with their higher studies in Europe
as a father you always want to make
decision that have a positive impact on
your children as for me I am going to
live my dream now I think dreams come
true when you work hard to achieve them
the future is in the cloud and it's
waiting for you to seize it
unleash the magic of cloud computing and
witness the floodgates open as your
website attracts a tidal wave of organic
traffic and enjoys unrivaled success in
the digital realm imagine you're the
owner of a small software development
firm and you want to scale your business
up however a small team size the
unpredictability of demand and limited
resources are roadblocks for this
expansion that's when you hear about
cloud computing but before investing
money into it you decide to draw up the
differences between on-premise and
cloud-based Computing to make a better
decision
when it comes to scalability you pay
more for an on-premise setup and get
lesser options too
once you've scaled up it is difficult to
scale down
and often leads to heavy losses in terms
of infrastructure and maintenance costs
cloud computing on the other hand allows
you to pay only for how much you use
with much easier and faster Provisions
for scaling up or down
next let's talk about server storage
on-premise systems need a lot of space
for their servers notwithstanding the
power and maintenance hassles that come
with them on the other hand cloud
computing Solutions are offered by cloud
service providers who manage and
maintain the servers saving you both
money and space then we have data
security on-premise systems offer less
data security thanks to a complicated
combination of physical and traditional
I.T security measures whereas cloud
computing systems offer much better
security and lets you avoid having to
constantly Monitor and manage security
protocols in the event that a data loss
does occur the chance for data recovery
with on-premise setups are very small in
contrast cloud computing systems have
robust disaster recovery measures in
place to ensure faster and easier data
recovery
finally we have maintenance on-premises
systems also require additional teams
for hardware and software maintenance
loading up the costs by a considerable
degree
cloud computing systems on the other
hand are maintained by the cloud service
providers reducing your costs and
resource allocation substantially so now
thinking that cloud computing is a
better option you decide to take a
closer look at what exactly cloud
computing is
cloud computing refers to the delivery
of on-demand Computing Services over the
internet on a pay-as-you-go basis in
simpler words rather than managing files
and services on a local storage device
you'll be doing the same over the
internet in a cost efficient manner
cloud computing has two types of models
deployment model and service model
there are three types of deployment
models public private and hybrid Cloud
imagine you're traveling to work you've
got three options to choose from one you
have buses which represent public clouds
in this case the cloud infrastructure is
available to the public over the
internet
these are owned by cloud service
providers two then you have the option
of using your own car this represents
the private cloud with the private Cloud
the cloud infrastructure is exclusively
operated by a single organization this
can be managed by the organization or a
third party and finally you have the
option to Hell a cab this represents the
hybrid cloud
a hybrid cloud is a combination of the
functionalities of both public and
private clouds
next let's have a look at the service
models there are three major service
models available es pass and SAS
compared to on-premise models where
you'll need to manage and maintain every
component including applications data
virtualization and middleware cloud
computing service models are hassle free
is refers to infrastructure as a service
it is a cloud service model where users
get access to basic Computing
infrastructure they are commonly used by
it administrators if your organization
requires resources like storage or
virtual machines is the model for you
you only have to manage the data runtime
middleware applications and the OS while
the rest is handled by the cloud
providers next we have pass
pass or platform as a service provides
Cloud platforms and runtime environments
for developing testing and managing
applications this service model enables
users to deploy applications without the
need to acquire manage and maintain the
related architecture
if your organization is in need of a
platform for creating software
applications pass is the model for you
pass only requires you to handle the
applications and the data the rest of
the components like runtime middleware
operating systems servers storage and
others are handled by the cloud service
providers and finally we have SAS SAS or
software as a service involves cloud
services for hosting and managing your
software applications
software and Hardware requirements are
satisfied by the vendors so you don't
have to manage any of those aspects of
the solution
if you'd rather not worry about the
hassles of owning any it equipment the
SAS model would be the one to go with
SAS the cloud service provider handles
all components of the solution required
by the organization so if you are ready
to embark
contact postgraduate program in cloud
computing this comprehensive program
will equip you with the knowledge and
skills needed to navigate the cloud
landscape with confidence dive deep into
Cloud architecture deployment models
security and migration strategies
explore platforms like Amazon web
services Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform to build your Cloud
expertise not miss out on this chance to
transform your career and join the ranks
of successful Cloud professionals click
the link in the description box below to
discover more about the cloud computing
Basics course to know more about this
course click on the link mentioned in
the description box below what is cloud
computing as we learn what is cloud
computing we will also be learning about
how things were before cloud computing
and benefits of cloud computing
different types of cloud computing
available and some of the famous
companies that are using cloud computing
and they're getting benefited out of it
we're going to learn all that before
cloud computing existed if we need any
it servers or application let's say a
basic web server it does not come easy
now here is an owner of a business and I
know you would have guessed it already
that he's running a successful business
by looking at the hot and fresh brewed
coffee in his desk and lots and lots of
paperwork to review and approve now he
had a smart not only smart looking but a
really smart worker in his office called
Mark and on one fine day he called Mark
and said that he would like to do
business online in other words he would
like to take his business online and for
that he needed his own website as the
first thing and Mark puts all his
knowledge together and comes up with
this requirement that his boss would
need lots of servers database and
softwares to get his business online
which means a lot of investment and Mark
also adds that his boss will need to
invest on acquiring technical expertise
to manage the hardware and software that
they will be purchasing and also to
monitor the infrastructure and after
hearing all this his boss was close to
dropping his plan to go online but
before he made a decision he chose to
check if there are any alternatives
where he don't have to spend a lot of
money and don't have to spend acquiring
technical expertise now that's when Mark
opened this discussion with his boss and
he explained his boss about cloud
computing and he explained his boss the
same thing that I'm going to explain to
you in some time now about what is cloud
computing what is cloud computing cloud
computing is the use of a network of
remote servers hosted on the internet to
store manage and process data rather
than having all that locally and using
local server for that cloud computing is
also storing our data in the internet
from anywhere and accessing our data
from anywhere throughout the internet
and the companies that offer those
services are called Cloud providers
cloud computing is also being able to
deploy and manage our applications
services and network throughout the
globe and manage them through the web
management or configuration portal in
other words cloud computing service
providers give us the ability to manage
our applications and services through a
Global Network or Internet example of
such providers are Amazon web servers
and Microsoft Azure now that we have
known what cloud computing is let's talk
about the benefits of cloud computing
now I need to tell you the cloud
benefits is what is driving Cloud
adoption like anything in the recent
days if you want an I.T resource or a
service now with Cloud it's available
for me almost instantaneously and it's
ready for production almost the same
time now this reduces the go live date
and the product and the service hit the
market almost instantaneously compared
to the Legacy environment and because of
this the companies have started to
generate Revenue almost the next day if
not the same day planning and buying the
right size Hardware has always been a
challenge in Legacy environment and if
you're not careful when doing this we
might need to live with a hardware
that's undersized for the rest of our
lives with Cloud we do not buy any
hardware but we use the hardware and pay
for the time we use it if that Hardware
does not fit our requirement release it
and start using a better configuration
and pay only for the time you use that
new and better configuration in Legacy
environments forecasting demand is an
and full-time job but with Cloud you can
let the monitoring and automation tool
to work for you and to rapidly scale up
and down the resources based on the need
of that R not only that the resources
Services data can be accessed from
anywhere as long as we are connected to
the internet and even there are tools
and techniques now available which will
let you to work offline and will sync
whenever the internet is available
making sure the data is stored in
durable storage and in a secure fashion
is the talk of the business and Cloud
answers that million dollar question
with Cloud the data can be stored in a
highly durable storage and replicated to
multiple regions if you want and the
data that we store is encrypted and
secured in a fashion that's beyond what
we can imagine in local data centers now
let's bleed into the discussion about
the types of cloud computing very lately
there are multiple ways to categorize
cloud computing because it's ever
growing now we have more categories out
of all these six sort of stand out you
know categorizing cloud based on
deployments and categorizing cloud based
on services and again under deployments
categorizing them based on how they have
been implemented you know is it private
is it public or is it hybrid and again
categorizing them based on the service
it provides is it infrastructure as a
service or is it platform as a service
or is it software as a service let's
look at them one by one let's talk about
the different types of cloud based on
the deployment models first in public
Cloud everything is stored and accessed
in and through the internet and any
internet users with proper permissions
can be given access to some of the
applications and resources and in public
Cloud we literally own nothing be it the
hardware or software everything is
managed by the provider AWS Azure and
Google are some examples of public Cloud
private Cloud on the other hand with
private Cloud the infrastructure is
exclusively for an single organization
the organizations can choose to run
their own cloud locally or choose to
Outsource it to a public cloud provider
as managed services and when this is
done this service the infrastructure
will be maintained on a private Network
some examples are VMware cloud and some
of the AWS products are very good
example for private Cloud hybrid cloud
has taken things to the whole new level
with hybrid Cloud we get the benefit of
both public and private Cloud
organizations will choose to keep some
of their applications locally and some
of the application will be present in
the cloud one good example is NASA it
uses hybrid Cloud it uses private Cloud
to store sensitive data and uses public
Cloud to store and share data which are
not sensitive or confidential let's now
discuss about cloud based on service
model
the first and the broader category is
infrastructure as a service here we
would rent the service network storage
and we'll pay for them in an hourly
basis but we will have access to the
resources we provision and for some we
will have root level access as well ec2
in AWS is a very good example it's a VM
for which we have root level access to
the OS and admin access to the hardware
the next type of service model would be
platform as a service now in this model
the providers will give me a pre-built
platform where we can deploy our codes
and our applications and they will be up
and running we only need to manage the
codes and not the infrastructure here in
software as a service the cloud
providers sell the end product which is
a software or an application and we
directly buy the software on a
subscription basis it's not the infra or
the platform but the end product or the
software or a functioning application
and we pay for the hours we use the
software and in here the client
maintains full control of the software
and does not maintain any equipment
Amazon and Azure also sell products that
are software assets this chart sort of
explains the difference between the four
models starting from on-premises to
infrastructure as a service to platform
as a service to software as a service
this is self-explanatory that the
resource managed by us are huge in
on-premises that towards your left as
you watch and it's little less in
infrastructure as a service as we move
further towards the right and further
reduced in platform as a service and
there's really nothing to manage when it
comes to software as a service because
we buy this software not any
infrastructure component attached to it
there are lots of famous well-known
organizations around the world they have
moved or have migrated to the cloud
environment painting rest is one company
which is one of the world's largest
visual book marketing tool with more
than 70 million monthly active users now
Pinterest was able to scale its business
because it was all built on Amazon web
services with a company with a less
number of employees Pinterest decided
that they do not want a dedicated staff
time to manage a data center instead
Pinterest uses AWS or they used AWS to
manage their high performance social
application and store more than 8
billion objects and 400 terabytes of
data in AWS Cloud using a service called
Amazon simple storage service or in
short Amazon S3 and not only that they
are running 2 lakh 25 000 instance hours
a month and they run that on Amazon
compute service called Amazon ec2 or
Amazon elastic compute Cloud Spotify is
an another company that got benefited
using AWS it's an online music service
offering and it offers instant access to
over 16 million licensed songs Spotify
needed a peculiar requirement it needed
a storage solution that could scale very
quickly without incurring long lead
times for upgrades long story short
Spotify used Amazon S3 which is Amazon
simple storage service and Amazon S3
gave them the confidence in their
ability and to expand their storage
quickly while also providing High data
durability the third biggest company I
want to mention is Netflix it's the
world's largest internet television
network with more than 100 million
members in more than 190 countries
Netflix uses Amazon web services for
nearly all its Computing and storage
needs now that includes database
analytic recommendation Engines video
transcoding and a lot more not only that
this company is planning to use AWS
Lambda to build an automated or an
rule-based self-managing infrastructure
and replace some of their inefficient
process to reduce the rate of errors and
replace inefficient processes to reduce
the rate of errors and save their
valuable time Expedia is another famous
company that got benefited by using
Cloud Expedia provides travel booking
service through its Flagship site called
expedia.com and not only that they also
run 200 plus travel booking sites around
the world Xperia is all on AWS and by
using AWS Expedia has become more
resilient with an high scalable
infrastructure and better cloud services
because it had offloaded the it
management to the cloud provider itself
in this case AWS and because of this
Xperia's developers have been able to
innovate faster while saving the company
millions and millions of dollars so if
you are ready to embark on this exciting
your path look no further than simply
learn scaltech postgraduate program in
cloud computing this comprehensive
program will equip you with the
knowledge and skills needed to navigate
the cloud landscape with confidence dive
deep into Cloud architecture deployment
models security and migration strategies
explore platforms like Amazon web
services Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform to build your Cloud
expertise don't miss out on this chance
to transform your career and join the
ranks of successful Cloud professionals
click the link in the description box
below to discover more about the cloud
computing Basics course to know more
about this course click on the link
mentioned in the description box below
we can categorize the different types of
cloud computing based on two white
categories one being deployment model
and the other one being service model
let's talk about the deployment model
first deployment model is categorized
into three types first one is public and
then private and then hybrid cloud in
other words public Cloud private cloud
and hybrid Cloud it'll be easy for me to
explain and also it will be easy for you
to understand if I walk you through this
example consider the different types of
vehicles we use to commute from one
place to another for example if I want
to travel I can pick a bus which is
accessible to anyone I get in and I pay
for the seat that I occupy and I pay for
the time that I will be traveling in it
and I'm done cost is very less here a
similar kind of thing happens in the
public Cloud I pay only for the resource
that I use and I pay for how long I use
it if I use less I pay less if I use
more I pay more for that month simple on
the other hand private cloud is like
buying your own car and using it for
commuting purpose here I pay a huge
amount upfront and it is all owned only
by me I do not pay for it in an hourly
fashion but completely and all upfront
the cost here is very huge and thirdly
if I want the best of both types like
the comfort of the own car and still
don't want to pay all upfront otherwise
wise one only to pay for the time that I
use the service I can rent a car
similarly I can have it in a hybrid
environment meaning if I already have a
DC I can integrate it with the cloud and
use both the DCS and that would become
an hybrid environment all right so that
was good of in learning let's summarize
the types of cloud based on deployment
models and as we know now about the
public Cloud public cloud is and Cloud
infrastructure that's made available to
the general public over the internet and
it is owned by the cloud provider some
of the major players as Cloud providers
are AWS Microsoft Azure IBM's blue cloud
and Sun Cloud and private Cloud now this
Cloud infrastructure is exclusively
operated by a single organization it can
be managed by organizations or third
party and may exist on-premises or
off-premises doesn't matter but the
point here is this is exclusively
operated for a single organization and
some companies that provide private
Cloud are AWS and VMware and hybrid
Cloud gives the best of both public and
the private Cloud for example the
federal agencies they opt for private
clouds for storing and developing
personal data and they use public Cloud
to share the non-sensitive data with the
general public or with other government
departments now let's talk about
different clouds based on the service
model if we need to categorize them
broadly we can categorize them as
infrastructure as a service IAS or
platform as a service Pas or software as
a service SAS they sometimes are
referred to as is and says now at this
moment you could be like this guy
thinking Sam I thought you're done
categorizing the cloud now you're going
to talk about three more categories
which one should I pick well let me
explain if all that you want is just in
VM and you have all the expertise to
install the software on top of it and
make it work then go for I is if you
only want a platform or an interfaced
program or an interface to upload a
program and make it run then pick pass
or if all that you want is a finished
product hosted in the cloud and be able
to access it through the internet then
go for SAS here you get a username and
password for an application and you can
begin to customize the application based
on your needs alright let's talk about
is in a bit more detail I as it gives
basic Computing infra it's based on a
pay for what you use model and some of
the cloud providers who are big players
are AWS Azure and Google and here the
users generally will be it admins in Pas
the provider gives you a platform or a
runtime environment for developing
testing and managing application it's
platform ready you buy the platform you
upload a code and you start working on
it and it allows the software developers
to deploy applications without running
the underlying infrastructure and as you
might have guessed by now the
interesting candidates who would use Paz
is software developers and in SAS
everything is managed by the vendor be
it the hardware or the software it's
managed by the vendor and we pay for the
service and we pay for it through a pay
as you go subscription model and as you
might have guessed the end users here
would be End customer itself all right
let's put together everything in the
same page and compare and contrast the
different types of service models in
this chart it explains the difference
between the four models starting from
on-premises to is and then pass and says
it is self-explanatory that the
resources managed by us are huge in
on-premises and little less in is and
further less or reduced in Paz and
nothing to manage when it comes to SAS
let me also explain the different types
of cloud services through an example
like this let's say that you have a
crush on cake and you're planning to
bake one yourself now let's look at the
options you can have you can make all
the ingredients yourself be the floor
butter and you know put together and
bake the whole thing yourself using your
own oven pan you know the needed water
and the rest you get an idea right
everything is yours and that's on
premises all that you use is owned by
you and nothing is managed by the vendor
the other options you can have is buy
the ingredients and mix and bake the
cake yourself now this would be like is
here the infra is managed by the
provider and we get to use it and
customize it the way we want it here the
cloud service is in shared
responsibility the other options you
still have on hand is simply pick a
phone and order a cake now this is a lot
simpler than the rest we discussed so
far you know it's simply picking the
phone and ordering the cake and pay for
it when it arrives simple and when it
reaches home you will have to arrange
the table garnish the k take if that's
needed and then enjoy the cake it's the
same way with pass just get the platform
in which you would run your code and
upload your code and start running your
application here you and the vendors
still share the responsibility you still
have one more option left that is simply
go out and dine this is a lot lot
simpler that it requires no effort from
us at all you buy the fully finished and
garnished cake and pay for it and walk
out no responsibility on making the cake
it's the same way with SAS we buy the
finished product and pay for the
finished application so if you are ready
to embark on this exciting career path
Caltech postgraduate program in cloud
computing this comprehensive program
will equip you with the knowledge and
skills needed to navigate the cloud
landscape with confidence dive deep into
Cloud architecture deployment models
security and migration strategies
explore platforms like Amazon web
services Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform to build your Cloud
expertise don't miss out on this chance
to transform your career and join the
ranks of successful Cloud professionals
click the link in the description box
below to discover more about the cloud
computing Basics course to know more
about this course click on the link
mentioned in the description box below
now let's understand what do we mean by
the cloud computing architecture
so this diagram represents the cloud
computing architecture where you can see
there is a cloud infrastructure which we
call as a front-end front end means the
infrastructure that is Network facing
that is internet facing and the back end
is where actually the application the
services and the devices are like
storage servers and all along with the
management and the security portals so
primarily the cloud computing
architecture has two components one is
the front end and the other one is the
back end
now with respect to the architecture the
cloud computing is architecture as we
discussed earlier is divided into two
parts front end and the back end it
provides applications and interfaces
that are required for the cloud-based
services
so front end would be anything which is
facing the internet for example the
websites that you deploy they are front
end because they are accessed by the
public over the public network
these applications basically such as web
browser Google Chrome and Internet
Explorer over which you can basically
open up your web applications your
websites and also it includes client and
mobile devices along with some apis
so this is with respect to the front-end
architecture now let's look into the
furthermore concepts related to the
front end so in the front end the cloud
infrastructure consists of a hardware
and the software components that
includes a data storage server
virtualization software Etc
also it provides the GUI we call it as a
graphical user interface to the end
users so that they can perform the
respective task so it's a GUI based
access and those who are not from the
coding background or they don't have
familiarity with the CLI it is an
advantage
now let's understand the back end
architecture
so the back end is basically it manages
all the programs that runs
the application on the front end so
whatever is required to support the
applications for example web
applications which are running on a
front end
would be available in the back end
it has the larger number of data storage
systems and server so it is basically it
comprises of the entire infrastructure
of a cloud provider and it can also be a
software or it can be a platform as well
So based on the requirement the
application provides output to the end
users in the back end
also it is one of the most important
components in the cloud because it is
you can say a backbone of a cloud
computing architecture
and its task is to provide utility in
the architecture and the few services
that are widely used among the end users
are storage application development
environments and the web services
in the back end with respect to the
storage it maintains and manages any
time of any amount of data over the
internet
some of the examples of storage services
on the cloud are S3 which is called as a
simple storage service Oracle cloud
storage and Microsoft Azure storage
the storage capacity varies depending
upon the service providers available in
the market
and also it allocates specific resources
to a specific task it handles functions
of cloud environment so this is with
respect to the management in the backend
architecture the management in the
backend architecture helps thin the
management of components like
applications tasks service security data
storage and the cloud infrastructure
and in simple terms it establishes
coordination among the resources
coming to the security aspect of a
back-end architecture
it is an integral part of a crowd
infrastructure because since you it
mostly relies on the storage and the
databases so it has to be more secure it
helps in protecting Cloud resources
system files and the infrastructures
also it provides security to the cloud
servers with virtual firewalls and
results in the prevention data loss
now the different components of the
cloud computing architecture one is the
hypervisor second is the management
software
the third one is the deployment software
fourth one is the network
fifth one is the Cloud Server
and you have the cloud storage
now let's look into what we have with
the hypervisor hypervisor as the name
suggests is a virtual operating platform
and that is basically used by every user
it runs a separate virtual machine on
the back end which consists of a
software and the hardware
also it maintain objective its main
objective is to divide and allocate
resources so basically the hypervisor is
primarily used to virtualize the
physical machines so that it can be
shared across with many resources or
many users
the management software its
responsibility is to manage and monitor
the cloud operations so all the
operational tasks are basically done by
the management software
it helps in improving the performance of
the cloud since you can do the admin
task as well for example high security
flexibility full-time access and the
access given to other users who would be
working on the cloud platform
the deployment software consists of all
the mandatory installations and
configurations that are required to run
a cloud service
every deployment of cloud services
performed using a deployment software so
it is primarily used for deploying the
applications or a software so that
basically saves the time of a developer
in terms of deploying their codes
now the three different models which can
be deployed are the software as a
service which we call as a SAS so the
software as a service means it holds the
software and manage the application of
the end user example is Gmail so Gmail
is an example of a SAS service where it
acts as a mailing service and the users
just have to create their email accounts
and start using the service
uh the pass is basically a platform as a
service and it helps to develop and
build and deploy the applications on the
software primarily used by the coders
they can concentrate more on their
development activities and less focus on
the infrastructure part
example is Microsoft Azure and the
infrastructure as a service IIs is
basically to provide services on pay as
you go pricing model
coming to the component of a cloud
computing architecture that is Network
so what is with respect to network why
do we need a network so it connects the
front end and the back end together
so the network can be the internal
private network of a cloud computing
provider as well as the public network
and also it allows every user to access
the cloud resources over the internet
it helps users to connect and customize
the route and protocols so let's say an
admin wants a particular IPS to be
blocked so you can specify them and
customize them in the route and the
protocols
it is a virtual server which is hosted
on the cloud computing architecture so
it is just like a virtual networking
that is available on the cloud computing
platform
it is highly flexible secure and cost
effective and it is basically uh you can
say the backbone in terms of connecting
multiple Services together
the cloud storage is basically where
every data is stored and that can be
accessed by a user from anywhere over
the Internet of course it depends on how
do you provide the access to it
it is scalable at runtime and it is
automatically accessed
and the data can be modified and
retrieved from the cloud storage over
the Internet itself for a better
understanding let's consider a scenario
consider baking lasagna you have four
options you can either bake it at home
or you can go to a restaurant to eat
lasagna or walk into an event and bake
or get it delivered to your doorstep but
how is this related to cloud computing
well let's take a look we have four
boxes we have the traditional method we
have the infrastructure as a service we
have platform as a service and we have
software as a service in the traditional
method everything is made at home and
all the components are managed by us
that is Kitchen electricity microwave
lasagna sheets then toppings meat and
cooking the lasagna but when it comes to
infrastructure service the main kitchen
appliances are managed by the vendor and
the other things are managed by us so
basically the infrastructure is managed
by the vendor when we look at platform
as service the infrastructure and the
main ingredient for the soft software is
managed by the vendor and the other
things are managed by us but when we
look at software as a service everything
from the infrastructure till the end
product is managed by the vendor now
let's get into brief of all this when we
look at the traditional method
everything is done from the scratch from
choosing the right ingredients to the
mode of preparation and you have the
full control of the toppings this is
similar to traditional method where all
the hardware and software components are
built by a choice of requirements when
you look at infrastructure as a service
we can say kitchen electricity and
microwave is the infrastructure and this
is where the code runs the next step is
to alter the software as per our
requirements when you look at platform
as a service it's similar to going to
event and baking so you have the main
ingredient that is the lasagna sheet and
then you have all the appliances that is
Kitchen electricity and microwave and
the rest is managed whereas you can
either put toppings or you don't want to
put meat or you want it to be Veg it's
all up to us so the comp movements are
altered as per our requirements finally
in software as a service the entire
thing is modeled by the vendor so this
is where you just given your
requirements and you get the software
delivered to you it's basically where
the deployment and framework of the
project is already set now that we have
a brief of all these Services let's dive
deep into each one of them first we have
infrastructure as a service
infrastructure cloud provider gives a
variety of infrastructures such as
storage Services Network hardware and so
on it also maintains and supports these
infrastructures customers can access
these resources over the internet
next let's look at the benefits of
infrastructure as a service
the first feature is that these
resources can easily be scaled up and
down next the cost depends on the
consumption so basically it's a pay as
you go pricing and you pay for what you
use you pay for the services you use a
single piece of server can give out a
lot of information to many users and
finally the client has complete control
over the architecture now let's look at
the pros of infrastructure as a service
model firstly it is highly flexible this
is because only the infrastructure is
provided and the rest depends on the
customer requirements next like I said
before it is cost effective and you pay
for what you use it is easy to use as
all the updates are deployed and all the
hardware is deployed automatically
management tasks are virtualized so that
the other employees have time for other
tasks now let's look at few of it's gone
it is a multi-tenant architecture due to
this there is an issue with data
security when a new infrastructure is
introduced team training is required to
learn all about this new infrastructure
and it consumes a lot of time if in case
the server crashes at the vendor site
the customers cannot access the data for
a while and they would have to wait for
a quite a lot of time until the vendor
fixes this issue now that we know what
infrastructure as a service is let's
look at platform as a service platform
as a service cloud computing platform is
a developer programming platform which
is used for the programmers to develop
test and run and manage the applications
a developer drives the applications and
deploys it directly into this layer all
the infrastructure to run the
applications will be over the Internet
let's look at the benefits now firstly
the resources can be scaled Up and Down
based on the requirements of the user
multiple users can access the same
application it allows for testing and
hosting apps in the same environment the
web services and databases and servers
are integrated into one and finally the
teams can collaborate very easily next
let's look at the pros of of paas
firstly the development process is quick
and easy as it is a developer
programming platform it is cost
efficient you only pay for those
Services you use when you use platform
as a service the coding is done by the
developer before so less coding is
required and then the migration to
hybrid cloud is very easy next let's
look at few of the cons of platform as a
service similar to iaas data security is
an issue because it has a multi-tenant
architecture there is a compatibility
issue with the existing infrastructure
pass is dependent on the vendor speed
reliability and support now that we know
about platform as a service let's go
ahead and dive deep into software as a
service in software as a service
everything is done by the vendors the
end users are only responsible to give
their requirements and everything is
done by the providers now let's go ahead
and look at its benefits the
installations and updations are done by
the providers resources are scaled Up
and Down based on the requirements of
the users the only requirement is that
there has to be a strong network
connectivity and finally the provider is
responsible for everything now let's go
ahead and look at the pros of SAS
upgrades are automatic firstly then next
it is again a pay as you go model it is
easier to customize in SAS rather than
the other service models it is
accessible from any location the only
constraint is that you need to have a
strong internet connectivity let's see
the cons of SAS the provider has entire
control the end users only have the
control of giving the requirements there
are only few solutions for software
crashes the devices should always be
connected for better performance now
that we've seen all the three models
let's see few of the companies providing
these service models the famous IAS
providers are Amazon web services
Rackspace digitalocean linode and
Microsoft Azure these are only a few
there are many move apart from this
Amazon offers many features such as Auto
scaling Cloud monitoring and load
balancing features when it comes to
Rackspace the cloud computing platform
vendor focuses primarily on Enterprise
level hosting Services when you look at
Famous past providers you have heroko
Apache Stratos open shift Microsoft
Azure and many other providers going
ahead in SAS providers the most
important one is Google Apps then
there's Salesforce there is Cisco WebEx
this Dropbox and many more finally let's
look at the end users of the cloud
computing service models we can picture
this as a pyramid so in iaas the end
uses a system admins who are responsible
for maintaining everything except the
infrastructure then in pass the end
users of the developers who code on the
platform provided by the vendors in SAS
the end users are the customers who give
only the requirements and the software
is built based on those requirements by
the vendors meet Rob he runs an online
shopping portal the portal started with
a modest number of users but has
recently been seeing a surge in the
number of visitors on Black Friday and
other holidays the portal saw so many
visitors that the servers were unable to
handle the traffic and crashed is there
a way to improve performance without
having to invest in a new server
wondered rob a way to upscale or
downscale capacity depending on the
number of users visiting the website at
any given point well there is Amazon web
services one of the leaders in the cloud
computing Market before we see how AWS
can solve Rob's problem let's have a
look at how AWS reached the position it
is at now
AWS was first introduced in 2002 as a
means to provide tools and services to
developers to incorporate features of
amazon.com to their website in 2006 its
first Cloud Services offering was
introduced in 2016 AWS surpassed its 10
billion Revenue Target
and now AWS offers more than 100 cloud
services that span a wide range of
domains thanks to this the AWS cloud
service platform is now used by more
than 45 of the global market now let's
talk about what is AWS AWS or Amazon web
service is a secure cloud computing
platform that provides computing power
database networking content storage and
much more
the platform also works with a pay as
you go pricing model which means you
only pay for how much of the service is
offered by AWS you use some of the other
advantages of AWS are security AWS
provides a secure and durable platform
that offers end-to-end privacy and
security
experience you can benefit from the
infrastructure management practices born
from Amazon's years of experience
flexible it allows users to select the
OS language database and other services
easy to use users can host applications
quickly and securely scalable depending
on user requirements applications can be
scaled up or down AWS provides a wide
range of services across various domains
what if Rob wanted to create an
application for his online portal AWS
provides compute services that can
support the app development process from
start to finish from developing
deploying running to scaling the
application up or down based on the
requirements the popular Services
include ec2 AWS Lambda Amazon light cell
and elastic Beanstalk for storing
website data Rob could use AWS storage
services that would enable him to store
access govern and analyze data to ensure
that costs are reduced agility is
improved an innovation accelerated
popular services within this domain
include Amazon S3 PBS S3 Glacier and
elastic file storage
Rob can also store the user data in a
database with aw Services which he can
then optimize and manage popular
services in this domain include Amazon
RDS dynamodb and redshift if Rob's
businesses took off and he wanted to
separate his Cloud infrastructure or
scale up his work requests and much more
he would be able to do so with the
networking Services provided by AWS some
of the popular networking Services
include Amazon VPC Amazon Route 53 and
elastic load balancing other domains
that AWS provides services in are
analytics blockchain containers machine
learning internet of things and so on
and there you go that's AWS for you in a
nutshell so if you are ready to embark
on this exciting career path look no
further than simply learn skal Tech
postgraduate program in cloud computing
this comprehensive program will equip
you with the knowledge and skills needed
to navigate the cloud landscape with
confidence dive deep into Cloud
architecture deployment models security
and migration strategies explore
platforms like Amazon web services
Microsoft Azure and Google Cloud
platform to build your Cloud expertise
don't miss out on this chance to
transform your career and join the ranks
of successful Cloud professionals click
the link in the description box below to
discover more about the cloud computing
Basics course to know more about this
course click on the link mentioned in
the description box below coming to the
AWS services so essentially AWS services
are compute storage database migration
networking and content delivery
developer tools
management tools Media Services machine
learning analytics security identity and
compliance mobile services
application integration AR and VR which
is augmented reality and virtual reality
customer engagement business
productivity desktop and app streaming
internet offerings which is iot
now let's look into
the compute service which is one of the
widely used service on the AWS and what
does the compute service do these
Services help developers build deploy
and scale an application in the cloud
platform that is ec2
Lambda elastic container service elastic
load balancer light sail and elastic
bean stock these are the services which
lie in the compute service section only
one of the most widely used service
within the compute section is ec2 which
stands for elastic Cloud compute it is a
web service that allows developer to
rent virtual machines and helped to
resize the compute capacity
so here what you can do is you can run
the virtual machines and you have the
Privileges to select the type of
operating system that you want uh should
be running on your instances or on your
virtual machines and likewise later you
can customize as per your requirement
Lambda is a serverless compute service
it is also responsible to execute code
for a specific application so those who
are from the development background they
can focus more on creation of a code
they don't have to create a server
manage it instead they can use a Lambda
where you they can deploy their code
directly onto the Lambda server then
comes this storage service now couple of
storage services are S3 Glacier EBS
which is elastic block Storage storage
Gateway
now AWS provides web data storage
service for archiving data also its main
advantage is disaster data recovery with
high durability let's look into some of
the essential storage services and one
of the most widely used storage which is
S3 which stands for simple storage
service in the simple storage service
what you need to do is you have to
create a bucket and in that bucket you
have to put the files in it so S3 gives
open cloud-based storage service which
is utilized for online data backup then
comes the ABS which is an elastic block
storage now you can understand EBS as a
virtual hard drive also which attaches
with the ec2 and it provides High
availability storage volume for
persistent data it is mainly used by
Amazon ec2 instances then you have the
database Services AWS database domain
service offers cost efficient highly
secure and scalable database instances
in the cloud and some of the database
services are RDS which is a relational
database service
dynamodb the non-relational or nosql or
nosql database service elastic cache and
Amazon redshift now one of the essential
database service is the dynamodb it is a
flexible no SQL database service which
offers fast and reliable performance
with no scalability issues
it is fast reliable highly scalable and
suitable for small scale applications
like mobile applications gaming
applications or anything with respect to
the Internet of Things devices there the
dynamodb is uh most widely used or
suitable then comes the relational
database service that is the RDS which
is a structured database service
it is a managed distributed relational
database cloud service that helps
developers to operate and scale database
in a simple manner so RDS has different
vendors platform with respect to the
database usage and that includes the
postgresql MySQL then you have Oracle
Microsoft or Ms SQL and they have their
own
customize
database as well that is called as the
Amazon Aurora
along with that they have a Maria
database or Maria DB as well so these
are couple of vendors that give their
database engines that you can use on the
RDS now coming to the networking
Services it offers a highly secure Cloud
platform and helps in connecting your
physical Network to your private virtual
network with high transfer speed
now some of the services in the
networking and content delivery are VPC
which is a virtual private Cloud a very
important service in order to make your
applications or Services more secure
Route 53 which is a DNS mapping Service
Direct Connect which directly connects
with the AWS services and with your data
centers and the cloud front that is
basically a Content delivery service now
coming to the VPC or a virtual private
Cloud it helps a developer to deploy AWS
resources such as Amazon ec2 instances
in a private virtual Cloud so that you
can actually make your ec2 isolated or
make it more secure and even you can
make it for a public access also depends
on the administrator that how they want
to customize it so the complete control
of a VPC and its networking is with the
admins then comes the root 53 service
it is a web service with highly
available domain name system or the DNS
that helps user to Route software by
translating text into IP address and
that is why it is called as a DNS
mapping service and that helps you to
use your domains or the external domains
pointed to the AWS services in case if
you use AWS for hosting your websites or
the applications note DNS translates
text into the IP address now coming to
the developer tool services it helps a
user build deploy and run an application
source code automatically it also
updates the server and instance on the
workload so first is the code star code
build code deploy code pipeline so code
star it is a service designed to manage
application development at a single
place
here developers can quickly develop
build and deploy applications on AWS
so all the manage app development can be
done with the code star code build
removes the hassle of managing physical
servers and helps developer build and
test code with continuous scaling so
security identity and compliance
services
helps in monitoring a safe environment
for your AWS Resources by providing
limited access to specific users so in
case let's assume that you have to give
an access to someone but with limited
privileges you can primarily use IIM in
that case and if you want to make your
applications or
deployments more secure then you can use
these services like KMS IM Cognito
Waf which acts as a firewall now the IM
service which is the identity access
management is a framework that helps in
maintaining access to AWS services in a
secure way so what happens is that the
admin who has the complete access of the
AWS console provide access to users and
there can be different users and they
would have the privileged accesses
defined by the Admin so what type of
permissions the admin gives them they
would have those limited access on the
AWS console KMS enables users to create
and manage the encryption keys that are
used for encrypting data coming to
management tool services with the help
of management tools using the service an
individual can optimize cost minimize
risk and automate all the resources
running on the AWS infrastructure
efficiently so with the management tools
you can
monitor the resources application it's
its tools and the utilizations and along
with that you can scale up scale down
the resources likewise with the help of
the management tools you can also do the
auditing task so one of the essential
services in the management tool services
the cloud watch
it is a monitoring tool for AWS
resources and customer applications
running on AWS platform so let's assume
that you have used ec2 dynamodb S3 RDS
and you want to monitor those resources
you can use the cloud watch that can
give you the results coming to the cloud
formation
this service helps you in monitoring all
your AWS resources at one place so that
you can spend minimum time in managing
those resources and maximum time on
developing the application so with the
help of the cloud formation you can
deploy the entire solution with the help
of creation of a template you just need
to create one template and you have to
deploy it the rest of the things will be
done by the AWS and hence it is a kind
of an automation task only now let's
look into the demo of some of the
essential services
so we'll start with the ec2 and I have
already logged in into my AWS account so
where exactly you can find the ec2 just
click on the services
under the compute section you can find
the ec2 ec2 stands for elastic Cloud
compute service
primarily used for creating the virtual
machines
so I'll click on the service and quickly
I'll show you how the virtual machine is
created and how we can basically access
it
so I would be creating one virtual
machine or an instance with the Windows
operating system
so here you can see there are three
instances which are already running let
me create another one
we have to click on launch instances
and here you have to select some
configuration details
so most of the configuration details
I'll be taking as default
and wherever it is necessary I'll be
making the changes
so first of all you have to select the
operating system in the form of Ami and
I would be looking for Windows
2016 and then you have to select the
type of instance with respect to
the CPUs number of CPUs and the memory
capacity so I'll go with t2.micro which
is a free tier eligible instance
in the configure instance details the
rest of the things we'll keep it as
default as of now
click on add storage
this is a basically
the virtual hard drive or the EBS the
elastic block storage that is attached
with the ec2 instance
so primarily it is giving us 30 GB of
space without any additional cost
we can leave the tags as blank
click on configure security groups and
here you can see that the RDP Port is by
default open
which will actually allow us
to RDP or to have a remote connectivity
of our instance
click on review and launch
now to give an authentication or to
provide an authentication we should have
a key pair with us so that the AWS scan
understand or can tally the key pair and
give us the access
so I already have a key pair created
what I'll do is I'll create a new key
pair for this instance and put a random
name let's say I put it something like
demo
download the key pair
and make sure that you keep your key
pair in a safe and secure place
click on launch instances
now you will see that there is an
instance ID that has been created which
is a number alphanumeric number that is
randomly given by the AWS
you can name your instances
so let's assume let's say we name our
instance as
windows 2016.
click on Save
and
the AWS deploys our instance on a
respective infrastructure
it gives us the IP addresses the public
IP and the private IP which is an
internal IP and we have to access the
instance from the public IP only
so now to access that instance we have
to open up the RDP
put the public IP
click on connect
and when it asks you for the
Authentication
you put a username as administrator
and the password you have to generate by
providing the keep so click on connect
and then you have to click on RDP client
here you have to get a password so click
on get password
browse and when you click on browse you
have to provide demo dot pem file so it
should be in the download section here
itself
just provide that key pair and it is
going to give you the password in the
encrypted format
decrypt your password
copy that
and then provide those details
to the RDP client click on OK and now it
should allow you to login to the
instance let's wait for the windows to
appear so here you can see that we have
logged in into the windows instance the
windows 2016 screen is available in
front of us if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
this particular demonstration I would be
explaining you about
how to use a storage service
specifically the S3 service which is
most widely used service under the
storage section
now the S3 stands for simple storage
service primarily used for storing the
objects and the files
and what we need to do is we just have
to click on the S3 service under the
storage section
so when you click on S3 service you have
to create the buckets inside the S3
and the buckets are the places where you
keep your folders or you upload the
files that are available on your
systems
so
here if you'll notice that the S3
service is a global Service that means
it is irrespective of the region
and the buckets when you create they are
created in a specific region now what is
the benefit
the benefit is that if you create a
bucket in different regions all those
buckets in different regions can be
viewed from a single dashboard
and you don't have to change the region
again and again to view the S3 buckets
so what you need to do is you have to
click on create bucket
and here you have to specify the name of
the bucket so let's say I put something
like demo AWS
and uh
that's the bucket name I'm going to
select now make sure that the bucket
name starts with the lower case and it
should be always unique now why it
should be unique because since S3 is a
global Service so it may be that
somebody else could be using your
the name that you have provided so it
should be always unique otherwise it
will not be allocated
now you have to select a region and that
would be let's say I go with
the Ohio region
and in the bucket settings
you can basically change and configure
these settings according to your
requirement by default when you create a
bucket
it blocks all the public access from the
bucket so when you have all public
access blocked
no object can be viewed from the S3
Bucket from a public network or from or
by anyone else
and hence in order to
view the objects or the other files in
the bucket you have to unblock or
uncheck this option so that first of all
you make the bucket accessible from the
public network likewise you can
customize as per the requirement and
then click on acknowledgment the rest of
the things will keep it as default and
click on create bucket now it says that
the bucket with the same name already
exists so that means it is not a unique
name somebody else might have been using
this name so I'll try to keep it more
unique and I'll try to assign some
number so let's say I put something like
and it says it is already existed let's
say 9876
and then click on create bucket now if
it creates a bucket that means we have
been allocated with that bucket name so
let's wait for
wait for a minute to get that bucket
created
so that happens quickly and you can see
there are a couple of buckets already
created here and these buckets can be
viewed in a single dashboard
so some of the buckets are in Mumbai
region some of the buckets are in Ohio
region but they are available in the
same or a single dashboard so I'll open
up the bucket that I have recently
created and I'll try to upload some
documents now what you can do is you can
create a folder also inside the S3 and
when you create a folder you can upload
the objects accordingly otherwise you
can directly also upload the objects so
click on upload and we will upload any
random file from my system onto the sket
so I'll basically file
and then click on upload
now it is uploading my object from my
system onto the S3 bucket
and now it has successfully done so it
says the messages successful now in
order to validate I will click on the
bucket from the S3 service and view this
object
now you can see here is my bucket so
I'll just open up this bucket and these
dnsrecords.csv file is available with us
now the S3 is not only limited till
storing the objects or the files it has
many other functionalities and the
features also
like you can enable versioning you can
host a static website on the S3
along with that you can have a cross
region replication enabled so that you
can have a high availability of your
objects or you can have a redundancy of
your critical objects in different
regions so likewise there are more
features that would be covered up in the
details section of an S3 service now
coming to another
section of the essential services that
is the database
now here you can see I have a database
section in the AWS and it has multiple
service within
the RDS is there dynamodb is their
elastication the other database services
are there
so I would be showing a demo on the
dynamodbeam which is a no SQL database
now
when we say it is a nosql database that
means it is a non-relational database
service where we can create a database
table directly from the web console we
don't require a separate database engine
like in the case of RDS
and in the tables you can insert the
values and view those values directly
from the AWS dashboard itself
so it says Amazon dynamodb is a fast and
flexible nosql database service
primarily suitable for iot and web
gaming and other mobile applications
so what you need to do is it is a
straightforward database service which
is which can be accessed
while creating a table itself and it's a
compute based database service that is
the reason that it is more fast
so click on create table
and what you need to do is you just have
to put a table name so I'll just put
something like test
and uh in the partition key so these
partition keys are unique entities so
what you need to do is you have to
specify a partition key so I'll put
something like ID
and the string instead of string I'll
use a number
likewise I can add sort Keys Also let's
say I put a name
and the name should be in the string
format
now these are the unique entries these
are the fixed entries in the table and
after that we are going to put the
attributes and in the attributes the
data will be inserted so what you need
to do is rest of the things will keep it
as default as of now click on create
and
here you can see the table has been
created the test table has been created
now if I click on the items so you would
see that it has the sort Keys available
the ID and the sort key associated with
that that is the name but it does not
have any entry because we have not added
any value or the attributes so how we
can add or insert the values in this
table that can be done many ways
you can enter manually you can use the
help of CLI to enter the large chunk of
data directly upload it onto the
dynamodb table and also you can use the
apis also in order to insert the data
inside the table so what you will do is
we will click on create item
and in the ID we will put some value
let's say number one string let's say we
put something like
we will go with a random name so instead
of putting any name we'll put a value
like ABCD that should be fine and then
we will insert some attributes
so let's say I put
string as Rank and I'll put something
like rank 2.
and
then click on Save
so here you will see
just refresh the database table
close it and open it up again
click on the items
now here you can see the ID one name is
ABCD got the rank two likewise you can
click on create items let's say the
serial number or the id2 name let's say
we put something like we can go with XYZ
any random thing put it up as
number rank
and let's say this particular value got
a rank 3
likewise you can add some more items
string let's say you put something like
ajk
and
you put a rank let's say it's a rank
number one holder rank one holder
right so likewise uh this is just an
example likewise you can add the
attributes as per your need and the
table can be filtered out based on the
attributes also so if you have to search
some values in the dynamodb table so you
can always use filters uh to basically
search the values inside the table apart
from that the dynamodb table has lot of
other functionalities
it can be basically you can have a
backup
of a table created in the dynamodb table
in the Dynamo database and then you can
retrieve or recover the data by
restoring the backups from the dynamodb
this database can be created in the
cluster format also
so these are couple of features that you
can use with the dynamodb
now let's move into the next section
now coming to the networking services so
there are
some of the networking Services which
are very useful and that includes a VPC
which is a virtual private cloud cloud
front root 53 API Gateway Etc
now I will basically demonstrate about
the Route 53 service in this demo so in
the Route 53 is basically a DNS mapping
service so what you can do is let's
assume that you are hosting any web
application on the server and you want
to Route the domain traffic onto those
servers you need to have the help of
Route 53 to do that
so what you need to do is you just have
to click on Route 53 service
and from this service you can register
your domains also otherwise if you have
domains purchased from any external site
you can point them to the Route 53 name
servers also so first of all
in the Route 53 you have to create a
hosted zone so there is already one
hosted Zone all created
now when you create a hosted Zone you
have to specify the domain name
so let me show you I have one dummy
domain
what's the domain that has been defined
so what you have to do is when you click
on create hosted Zone you have to put a
domain here you can see example.com
likewise you have to put your own domain
and uh
click on the public hosted Zone
click on create hosted Zone and it is
going to give you four name server now
those four name servers have to be
updated
on
the platform from where you have
purchased the domain
so that is mandatory in order to Route
the traffic to the Route 53 service
right so here you can see I already have
a hosted Zone created for a domain
and it has given me
four name servers
these are the name servers and these
name servers have been updated
in a record set
from where the domain has been purchased
right
once it is done then you have to
route the domain traffic to a server so
what you have to do is you have to click
on create record
and in the create record you have to
specify
the IP address or you can use the Alias
also where the traffic should be routed
to where your application is hosted at
so ideally it is a server details
and it exists with certain
policies also
so you can see some view existing
records so here you can see
this particular domain
is routed to a DNS value which is hosted
in the elastic Beanstalk instead of that
you can put an IP address of the ec2
instance also you can use the S3 URL
also you can use the cloudfront URL also
so likewise what would happen is that
the domain traffic will be routed to the
server where actually the application or
a web application is hosted at
now I am using a routing policy as
simple routing policy that means all the
traffic should be routed to that
particular domain
whereas there are other routing policies
also in the Route 53 that includes the
weighted routing policy which acts as a
kind of a load balancing geolocation
routing policy multi-value answer
routing policy and then you have a
redundancy based routing policy which is
a failover one so likewise you can
select as per your requirement
so what you need to do is you just have
to click on create records uh you have
to specify you have the domain so you
have to specify any uh particular info
you want to put before the domain
otherwise you can leave it as blank and
in the record type let's assume that you
are using an IP address of a server
where your web application is hosted at
so you can basically use a routes
traffic to an ipv for address and put an
IP address make sure that you put a
public IP address or the elastic IP
address attached to your instance in
case if you are not using any particular
IP address or the URL you can use the
Alias also so likewise the records can
be created along with that the Route 53
Services used for domain verifications
also like if you want the email services
on onto your web application then you
can basically verify your domain
directly from the root 53 service you
can get the verification done for the
SSL certificate creation for that also
the records will be directly created
from the root 53 service because it is
actually managing or hosting your domain
now with respect to the security
services
the most widely used service is the IM
which is identity access management
that lies under security identity and
compliance
so in from the IM you can create the
user's uh whom you want to give an
access to your AWS console you can
create groups and you can add multiple
users in that group give them the
permissions you can create the rules
also so that multiple Services can
interact or integrate it together
so how the IM is used we click on the IM
service
and I'll show you how a particular user
can be created and how the user is
basically uses the credentials to access
the AWS console now the IM dashboard is
open and when you open up the IM
dashboard it gives you the URL so this
is the URL through which the user has to
actually
access the AWS console by providing the
user credentials now how the users are
created just click on the users
and
here you just have to click on add user
so I'll create one sample user let's say
I put something like sample user
and what type of an access you want to
give that particular user do you want to
give a programmatic access which is
primarily or the CLI access or you want
to give the AWS Management console so
right now we'll go with the AWS
Management console access
now do you want an auto generation of
the password or do you want to customize
the password so let's assume that we
customize the password so put any value
make sure the password meets all the
criterias
and uh
then click on next permissions now what
kind of permissions you want to give to
that user let's assume that you want to
give an access of a particular service
only to that user so you have to
actually search you have to actually
search a policy for that particular
service that can be given an access to a
user otherwise if you want to give an
admin policy or the admin access to that
user you can search an admin policy
there so the permissions are important
otherwise the user would not have
privileges to access
the AWS console
so
we'll attach the existing policies
directly so click on it
and here let's assume that I want to
give an admin access to that user so
I'll just click on the admin access now
to a particular user you can give
multiple policies also it is not
necessary that you have to give only a
single policy
so you can provide a multiple policies
to the users also now click on next tags
let let's make the tags blank click on
review and create a user
now you'll see that our sample user
would be created and to access the
console we'll just copy this URL which
has the account information as well that
is the account number
so copy the link or you can copy the
complete URL log out from the root
account
and then
paste the URL that was copied from the
console
and then we have to give the user
credentials
so we'll put sample user as the username
and the password that we provided while
creating the user
click on sign in and if it is correct
then it should allow us to login into
the AWS console while asking the
password change
so we'll change the password
confirm password change
and now it should allow us to login into
the root accounts AWS console with the
admin privileges
now the next service is the monitoring
services and under the monitoring
Services primarily the cloud watch the
cloud trail the cloud formation these
are some of the services that are most
widely used
now the cloud watch is a service which
is primarily used for monitoring the
metrics primarily of the servers like
for example if you create an ec2
instance and you want to basically
watch out for the
metrics associated with the CPU
utilization or the storage utilization
the network in network out all those
information you can get it from the
cloud watch
now cloudwatch is not only
related to monitoring the metrics it can
generate the alarms also and here you
can get the events also generated which
or the events that can be created which
can trigger the Lambda function as well
so what you have to do is you just have
to
click on a dashboard soil centering
metrics are viewed uh with the help of
the cloud watch so first of all you have
to create a dashboard
now you have to put a dashboard name
let's say I put something like
monitoring
ec2
click on create dashboard now how do you
want the reports to be published you
have to actually select a widget I want
that okay the report should be visible
in the numeric form so I'll select the
number
now click on the dashboard that was
created and uh
so again add the widget
and here uh we'll select the metrics
primarily for the ec2
for instance metric so we have one
single instance running now there are 14
metrics available for that particular
instance now I would be looking for the
CPU utilization for this particular
instance so I'll just select for the CPU
utilization and it is going to give me
some information about what is the
current CPU utilization of that
particular instance so that is somewhere
around 29.3 percent
uh the CPU utilization has been done for
the single instance that is running in
my ec2 dashboard so likewise you can add
some more metrics and view them in this
particular dashboard and the cloud watch
will keep on publishing the data at a
refresh interval of five minutes that is
uh the default value so if you are ready
to embark on this exciting career path
look no further than simply learn
scaltech postgraduate program in cloud
computing this comprehensive program
will equip you with the knowledge and
skills needed to navigate the cloud
landscape with confidence dive deep into
Cloud architecture deployment models
security and migration strategies
explore platforms like Amazon web
services Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform to build your Cloud
expertise don't miss out on this chance
to transform your career and join the
ranks of successful Cloud professionals
click the link in the description box
below to discover more about the cloud
computing Basics course to know more
about this course click on the link
mentioned in the description box below
so now what is azure what's the big
cloud service provider all about so
Azure is a cloud computing platform
provided by Microsoft now it's basically
an online portal through which you can
access and manage resources and services
now resources and services are nothing
but you know you can store your data and
you can transform the data using
services that Microsoft provides again
all you need is the internet and being
able to connect to the Azure portal then
you get access to all of the resources
and their services in case you want to
know more about how it's different from
its rival which is AWS I suggest you
click on the top right corner and watch
the AWS versus Azure video so that you
can clearly tell how both these cloud
service providers are different from
each other now here are some things that
you need to know about Azure if it's
launched in February 1st 2010 which is
significantly later than when AWS was
launched it's free to start and has a
pay-per-use model which means like I
said before you need to pay for the
services you use through Azure and one
of the most important selling points is
that 80 percent of Fortune 500 companies
use Azure Services which means that most
of the bigger companies of the world
actually recommend using Azure and then
Azure supports a wide variety of
programming languages the C sharp
node.js Java and so much more another
very important selling point of azure is
the amount of data centers it has across
the world now it's important for a cloud
service provider to have many data
centers around the world because it
means that they can provide their
services to a wider audience now Azure
has 42 which is more than any cloud
service provider has at the moment it
expects to have 12 more in a period of
time which brings its total number of
regions it covers to 54. now let's talk
about Azure Services now Azure Services
have 18 categories and more than 200
services so we clearly can't go through
all of them it has service sources that
cover compute a machine learning
integration management tools identity
devops web and so much more you're going
to have a hard time trying to find a
domain that Azure doesn't cover and if
it doesn't cover it now you can be
certain they're working on it as we
speak so first let's start with the
compute Services first virtual machine
with this service what you're getting to
do is to create a virtual machine of
Linux or Windows operating system it's
easily configurable you can add RAM you
can decrease RAM you can add storage
remove it all of it is possible in a
matter of seconds now let's talk about
the second service cloud service now
with this you can create a application
within the cloud and all of the work
after you deploy it deploying the
application that is is taken care of by
Azure which includes you know
provisioning the application load
balancing ensuring that the application
is in good health and all of the other
things are handled by Azure next up
let's talk about service fabric now with
service fabric the process of developing
a micro service is greatly simplified so
you might be wondering what exactly is a
micro service now a micro service is
basically an application that consists
of smaller applications coupled together
next up functions now with functions you
can create applications in any
programming language that you want
another very important part is that you
don't have to worry about any hardware
components you don't have to worry what
Ram you require or how much storage you
require all of that is taken care of by
Azure all you need is to provide the
code to Azure and it will execute it and
you don't have to worry about anything
else now let's talk about some
networking Services first up we have
Azure CDN or the content delivery
Network now the Azure CDN service is
basically for delivering web content to
users now this content is of high
bandwidth and can be transferred or can
be delivered to any person across the
world now these are actually a network
of servers that are placed in strategic
positions across the world so that the
customers can obtain this data as fast
as possible next up we have Express
start now with this you can actually
connect your on-premise network onto the
Microsoft cloud or any of the services
that you want through a private
connection so the only communication
that happens is between your on-premise
network and the service that you want
then you have virtual Network now with
virtual Network you can have any of the
Azure Services communicate with each
other in a secure manner in a private
manner next we have Azure DNS so Azure
DNS is a hosting service which allows
you to host their DNS or domain name
system domains in Azure so you can host
your application using Azure DNS now for
these storage Services first up we have
this storage with this storage you are
given a cost effective option of
choosing HDD or solid state drives to go
along with your virtual machines based
on your requirements then you have blob
storage now this is actually optimized
to ensure that they can store massive
amounts of unstructured data which can
include Text data or even binary data
next you have file storage which is a
manage file storage and can be
accessible via the SMB protocol or the
server message block protocol and
finally you have queue storage now with
queue storage you can provide durable
message queuing for an extremely large
workload and the most important part is
that this can be accessed from anywhere
in the world now let's talk about how
Azure can be used firstly for
application development which could be
any application mostly web applications
then you can test the application see
how well it works you can host the
application on the internet you can
create virtual machines like I mentioned
before with the service you can create
these virtual Machines of any size or
Ram that you want you can integrate and
Sync features you can collect and store
matrices for example how the data Works
how the current data is how you can
improve upon it all of that is possible
with these services and your virtual
hard drive switch is is an extension of
the virtual machines where these
services are able to provide you a large
amount of storage where data can be
stored let's talk about Azure Services
as I told you Azure provides services
for a wide range of domains now let's
have a look at some of these domains
there's Ai and machine learning compute
containers database identity management
tools networking Security Storage and so
much more now let's have a look at some
of the individual services within these
domains firstly you have Azure virtual
machines with Azure virtual machines
what you get is the opportunity to
create Windows or Linux virtual machines
now all of this is possible in a matter
of seconds with the large amount of
customization now let's have a look at
some of its features firstly you can
choose from a wide variety of virtual
machine options then you have a large
amount of optimization available to you
for example what size of operating
system do you want how much size do you
want allocated to it what version of the
system is it and so much more then it
provides low cost and permanent billing
now Azure provides you permanent billing
which means that you're only charged for
how much time you use the service and
finally you have enhanced security and
protection for your virtual machines
next we have service fabric now with
service fabric you have platform which
enables you to create micro Services now
this also makes the process of
application life cycle management a
whole lot easier as a direct result you
can create applications with a faster
time to Market it supports Windows Linux
on-premises or other clouds and it
enables you to do a tremendous amount of
scaling up depending on your requirement
and finally we have functions now with
functions you can build applications
with the help of serverless computing
here the users only pay for the amount
of resources that they've used you can
create applications in any language that
you want and the only thing you need to
worry about is the code of the
application everything other than that
that is the hardware requirements are
taken care of by Azure now let's have a
look at the networking Services firstly
we have the Azure CDN or the content
delivery network with Azure CDN what you
get is the ability to deliver your
content with reduced load times fast
responsiveness and less bandwidth now
CDN can be integrated with several other
Azure services so that the process can
move at a faster rate it can handle
heavy loads and traffic spikes with ease
it also provides a robust security
system now with the content that's
delivered you can get Advanced analytic
data with which you can understand how
customers are using your content next we
have express route with express route
you can connect your on-premises network
to Azure through a private Network Now
by default this lowest latency it
increases the emphasis on reliability
and speed and it can be of great use
when you have to transfer large amounts
of data between networks now another way
this can be useful is if it's used to
add compute or storage capacity to Data
Centers next we have Azure DNS domain
name service or Azure DNS can be used to
host your domain change on Azure this
provides High availability and great
performance it provides fast responses
to DNS queries by taking advantage of
Microsoft's Global Network it also
provides High availability next we have
virtual Network Azure virtual Network
allows the Azure resources to
communicate with each other or other
on-premise networks via the Internet and
all of this is kept extremely secure now
with this users can create their own
private Network for communication it
provides users with an isolated and
extremely secure environment for their
applications to run now all of the
traffic stays entirely within the Azure
Network and it also allows users to
design their own networks next we have
traffic manager now with traffic manager
you can route incoming traffic to
improve your performance and
availability now one thing it provides
is multiple failover options so if a
particular situation goes wrong there's
always an option to consider to salvage
the situation it helps reduce
application runtime and enables the
distribution of user traffic across
multiple locations it also helps the
people who are using it to know where
the customers connecting from across the
world next we have load balancer with
this you have provided the ability to
instantly scale applications at the same
time providing High availability and
improved Network performance for users
applications it can be integrated into
virtual machines and cloud services it
provides highly reliable applications it
also allows users to secure and
integrate security groups finally we
have Azure VPN Gateway now this allows
users to connect their on-premise
networks to Azure using a side-to-site
VPN now this allows users to connect
their virtual machine to anywhere in the
world through a point to site VPN and
also it's very easy to manage and is
highly available now let's talk about
the storage Services first we have data
Lake storage now with this what you get
is a scalable data storage with an
emphasis on cost Effectiveness and
scalability now it comes with Max
maximum use when you integrate it with
other services so that you can get
analytics on how the data is being used
it is also integrated with other
services like the Azure blob storage now
it is also optimized for Big Data
analysis tools like patchy spark and
Hadoop next up we have blob storage now
blob storage provides a storage capacity
for data now depending on how often a
particular data is used it is classified
into different tiers now all the data
that is within the blob storage is
unstructured data now it has a way of
ensuring that the data Integrity is
maintained every time a particular
object is being changed or the data is
being accessed and it also helps improve
app performance and reduces bandwidth
consumption next we have queue storage
now with this you have a message queuing
system for large workloads this allows
users to build flexible applications and
separate functions not to mention with
this you can be sure that your
individual components will not fail it
also makes sure that your application is
scalable Q storage provides queue
monitoring which helps ensure that the
customer's demands are met then we have
files stored now with file storage you
can perform file sharing with the help
of the SMB protocol or the server
message block protocol now this data is
protected by SMB 3.0 and the https
protocol in this case like we mentioned
in functions Azure takes care of all the
hardware needs and the operating system
deployments on its own it also improves
on-premises performance and other
capabilities lastly we have table
storage with table storage you can
deploy semi-structured data sets and
nosql key value store now this is used
for creating applications which have a
flexible data schema and also
considering how it has a very strong
consistency model it's mainly aimed for
end prices next let's have a look at
some web and mobile services first we
have the Azure search now with Azure
search you get a cloud search service
which is powered by artificial
intelligence with this you can develop
web application as well as mobile
applications now one big Advantage is
that you don't have to set up or manage
your search indices Azure takes care of
that and by extension it increases your
development speed the artificial
intelligence also will provide insights
and structured information that you can
use to improve the search as structured
information next we have logic apps now
with this you can create integration
Solutions which can connect applications
that are important to your business now
with this you can visually create
business processes and workflows you can
integrate SAS or software as a service
applications and Enterprise applications
and more importantly it allows you to
unlock data within a firewall and
securely connect to services next we
have web applications now with web apps
you can create deploy and scale web
applications according to business
requirements now it supports both
windows and Linux platforms and it helps
with continuous integration or
deployment abilities another very
important aspect of this is that the
data can be deployed and hosted across
multiple locations in the world and
finally we have mobile apps with mobile
apps you can create applications for iOS
Android and Windows platforms one
advantage is that it automatically
scales Up and Down based on your
requirements now in situations where you
have network issues offline data syncing
ensures that your applications work
anyway and you can create cross-platform
applications or native applications for
iOS Android and Windows next let's have
a look at some container services first
let's talk about ACS or Azure container
services it is also known as the Azure
kubernetes Services as it's a fully
managed kubernetes container
orchestration service now what this
means is that it eases the process of
container integration and deployment it
also can be used with other resources
from security like virtual networks
cryptographic keys and so much more to
ensure that your container is kept
secure next we have container instances
now this is similar to functions in a
way just that in this we're using
containers without having to manage
servers now applications can be
developed here without managing virtual
machines or learning new tools all that
is azure's problem to take care of and
it enables building applications without
having to manage the infrastructure that
is all you need to worry about is
running the container next let's have a
look at some database Services first we
have the SQL database now with SQL
database what you get is a relational
Cloud database service now this means
that it helps accelerate your app
development and makes it easier for you
to maintain your application now SQL
database is also used extensively in
migrating workloads to the cloud and
hence saves time and cost it also helps
improve your performance by integrating
machine learning and Adaptive
Technologies into your database next we
have Azure Cosmos DB now this is a
globally distributed multi-mart database
service now what this means is that with
this you can create application with
support nosql it provides a high grade
security system has high availability
and low latency now this is usually used
in situations where you have a diverse
and highly unpredictable workload now
let's have a look at some security and
identity Services firstly we have the
Azure active directory now if you want
to know more about Azure active
directory I suggest you click on the top
right corner and watch our video on the
Azure active directory this is just an
introduction so with this you can manage
user identities and you can make sure
the resources are kept safe with the
help of access policies most of these
are intelligence driven now one of the
main features is that you can have
access to your applications from any
location or device it helps increase
your efficiency and helps down cutting
costs when it comes to having a help
desk it can also help improve security
and can respond to Advanced threads in
real time next you have Azure active
directory b2c it helps provide customer
identity and access management in the
cloud now protecting customer identity
is extremely important for an
organization and that's what Azure adb2c
does now it also enables the application
to be scaled to great amounts even
billions of customers next we have the
Azure security Center this is basically
like a command post with which you get a
complete view of the security across
users on your on-premises and Cloud
workloads so with this you are given
threat protection method that adapts to
situations and helps reduce exposing you
to threads it also has rapid threat
response and makes the process of
finding and fixing vulnerabilities a
whole lot easier next up let's talk
about monitoring and Management Services
so first let's have a look at Azure
advisor now Azure advisor is basically a
guide for the best practices when it
comes to Azure now when you follow these
it improves performance secure security
cost and increases availability now it
also learns from how you use the
services on your configuration and usage
pattern and the adjustments that it
suggests can be implemented very quickly
and easily next we have Network Watcher
now with this you can monitor diagnose
and understand the working of your
network now you can monitor your network
without actually having to log in to
your virtual machine now you can also
use something known as network security
flow logs to understand the traffic
pattern how much traffic is coming
towards you how much you are giving and
so much more it also helps diagnose VPN
problems that you might have with detail
logs and finally you have the Azure
resource manager now with this you can
ensure that the resources that you have
are managed and deployed at a consistent
rate now this makes it extremely easy
for you to manage and visualize your
resources that are used in your
applications or some other requirements
and you can control who can access your
resources as well as perform actions on
it so if you are ready to embark on this
exciting career path look no further
than simply learn scaltech postgraduate
program in cloud computing this
comprehensive program will equip you
with the knowledge and skills needed to
navigate the cloud landscape with
confidence dive deep into Cloud
architecture deployment models security
and migration strategies explore
platforms like Amazon web services
Microsoft Azure and Google Cloud
platform to build your Cloud expertise
don't miss out on this chance to
transform your career and join the ranks
of successful Cloud professionals click
the link in the description box below to
discover more about the cloud computing
Basics course to know more about this
course click on the link mentioned in
the description box below let's
understand why Google Cloud platform so
Google Cloud platform is popular for
many reasons now let us see few of most
important reasons why it stands out
when you talk about pricing pricing is
one of the significant factors that make
Google Cloud Stand Out Among the other
Cloud providers
it offers a monthly pricing plan which
is billed according to monthly usage and
when we talk about billing here the
billing can be in hours it can be in
minutes and it can also be in seconds
there are different options when you
talk about your pricing which can be
found from your Google Cloud web page
now pricing could be based on preemptive
machines pricing could be based on
reserved instances or reserved resources
I'll show you the link where you can
find more details on pricing part of it
so Google Cloud really has various
pricing options which help customers in
their different requirements whether
they would go for any of the service
models such as infrastructure as a
service platform as a service or even
software as a service one more
attractive thing about Google Cloud
pricing is that it provides committed
use discounts
for example under this scheme you can
purchase a specific amount of virtual
CPU course and memory for up to 57
discount off regular prices if you
commit usage for either one or three
years now this is just one option there
are various such options which you can
learn about from the Google clouds page
and that really suits different
customers for their different
requirements
now when we talk about speed we don't
need to really challenge this aspect
when it comes to Google services so
Google provides its Google cloud and
Google app customer speed up to 10
terabytes because of its faster cable
system there are different kind of
machines which can be used if you are
talking about computation if you are
talking about memory hungry applications
or even storage intensive workloads okay
all in all speed is one of the defining
characteristics of Google cloud services
the cable has connections over us West
Coast main cities in Japan and even
major hubs in Asia this speed enhances
performances and leads to customer
satisfaction now when we talk about
customers any or every customer would
prefer to have low latency High
throughput Based Services they would
want to use higher speeds to process
their data in as less time as possible
Google provides a low latency Network
infrastructure in fact you can say that
when you are using Google cloud services
you are using the services from the same
infrastructure which Google uses for its
popular services such as Google search
or even YouTube which is one of the
second largest repository which can be
accessed for videos now when we talk
about Big Data big data is data which is
very complex has lot of other
characteristics such as your volume you
have velocity you have variety you have
velocity validity volatility virility
and so on so if an organization has is
working on Big Data Google Cloud can be
a better choice because Google has many
Innovative tools for cloud warehousing
for example such as bigquery and even
real-time data processing tools such as
data flow bigquery is a data warehouse
that allows massive processing of data
at high speeds basically working on your
structured data Google also has launched
some new machine learning from
artificial intelligence tools now there
are various other services which we can
which we can use from Google Cloud
platform but let's understand what is
Google Cloud platform and what are some
of the services even the services which
are not less tested here can be found in
your console from Google Cloud so what
is Google Cloud platform gcp it is a set
of Cloud Computing Services provided by
Google that runs on the same
infrastructure as I mentioned that
Google uses for its end user products
like YouTube Gmail and even Google
search the various set of services
offered by Google Cloud platform are so
you have Services which are specific to
Computing requirements and again in
Computing you have various different
options available you have machines
which are compute optimized machines
which are memory optimized machines
which are storage optimized and also we
have certain machines such as preemptif
which basically means that you could get
a machine to work on at a far lesser
price than any other machine but when we
talk about preemptive these are the
machines which can be requested on
demand and they can be taken back by
Google at any time you have networking
related Services which can be very
useful when you are setting up your
applications or your services across
Globe you also have different Services
which are specific to machine learning
and organizations which would be
interested in working on machine
learning or artificial intelligence
would be really interested in using
these Services there are also innovative
solutions to work on big data and Big
Data related Technologies now when we
talk about Google Cloud platform domains
so we can break down these Services into
specifics such as you have compute now
the compute service allows for computing
and hosting the cloud
now when you talk about Computing here
there are different services such as app
engine you have compute engine you have
kubernetes you have Cloud functions and
Cloud run when you talk about storage
and database so the storage and database
service allows application to store
media files backups or other file like
objects now various Services Under This
are as follows you have cloud storage
Cloud SQL Cloud bigtable for
unstructured data you have Cloud spanner
cloud data store persistent disks and
Cloud memory store when we talk about
networking the networking service allows
us to load balanced traffic across
resources now as I mentioned earlier
resources could be your different
resources which you would be using from
a cloud platform such as your devices
your instances memory optimize or CPU
optimized instances us or other
resources creating DNS records and much
more so various Services Under This are
VPC that stands for virtual private
Cloud you have Cloud load balancing
Cloud armor Cloud CDN you have Cloud
interconnect DNS and network service
tiers when we talk about the big data
service this allows us to process and
query big data in Cloud now various
Services under these are as follows you
have bigquery cloud cloud data proc
Cloud composer cloud data lab cloud data
prep Cloud Pub sub which is publishing
subscribing system you have cloud data
studio now you also have the developer
tools and developer Tools service
includes tools related to development of
an application now various Services
under these are as follows that is you
have Cloud SDK software development kit
you have deployment manager Cloud Source
Repository and Cloud test lab when we
talk about identity and security which
is one of the primary concerns for any
organization or any user who would be
interested in using a cloud platform
Google Cloud really has taken care of
this so when you talk about identity and
security domain this deals with Security
Services now various Services here are
Cloud identity you have identity and
access management that is cloud IAM you
have identity aware proxies you have
cloud data loss prevention API security
key enforcement Key Management Service
and many more
you also have cloud services which are
related to internet of things so very
much would be used by organizations who
would be working on iot devices or the
data generated by these devices so
various Services here are Cloud iot Core
you have Edge TPU and Cloud iot also
when we talk about Cloud AI that is
artificial intelligence this comprises
of services related to machine learning
and much more so you have Cloud Auto ml
Cloud TPU Cloud machine learning engine
job Discovery dialogue flow Enterprise
natural language Cloud text-to-speech
and much more
if you would be interested in Services
related to API platform then there are
different Services Under This category
or this domain so you have Maps platform
you have APG API platform monetization
developer portal analytics that is API
analytics APG sends Cloud endpoints and
service infrastructure so these are some
of the listing of services under each
Cloud platform domain now let's look at
Ferrero use case and let's also
understand what was done here so Ferrero
is one of the famous chocolate and ranks
third among worldwide chocolate and
confectionary producers it was found in
1946 in Italy I'm sure you would have
seen the federal chocolates when you
would have gone out to buy some
chocolates so the challenges here was
that Ferrero as we know is sold in every
supermarket and is known for its quality
once the prisoners grew some issues
arose right and that's what happens when
the business grows you have issues
popping up which could be related to the
volume of data the speed with which the
data is getting generated the variety of
data and also looking at your platforms
which support different Dynamic
applications or your scalability
requirements performance requirements
and so on
so it needed data storage processing and
Analysis system for a wide customer
database
there was a huge gap between the company
and the people who bought its goods
because the company relied on data given
sales outlets now that's one of the
challenge Ferrero wanted to create a
digital ecosystem where there was a
point of contact with its customers and
also a foundation for an Innovative
data-driven marketing strategy what was
the solution here so one of the service
of cloud platforms or Google Cloud
platform is bigquery and this was an
answer to ferrero's challenges since it
was capable of hyper fast and efficient
data analysis as a solution now as I
mentioned bigquery is a data warehouse
which allows you to store structured
data now this could directly be used as
a service where you could store in any
amount of data and you would not be
paying for storage so there are
different pricing models and for data up
to one terabytes you would not be
charged anything and if you would be
accessing the data that is reading the
data or processing the data from
bigquery that's where the pricing model
kicks in
Now using Google Cloud's bigquery
business analysts of Ferrero were able
to store and analyze massive data sets
in a very reliable fast and affordable
manner
consumer behavior and sales pattern data
reports were easy to build and automate
and the analysis also followed Ferrero
to adopt advertising across various
marketing channels to serve the customer
needs in a better way what was the
result
they could divide their database into
real-time actionable consumer clusters
to generate more accurate user profiles
Ferrero was also able to personalize its
marketing strategies to match the user
needs
now Google Cloud platform completely
tailored the website mobile content and
advertising and created a very cost
effective media by strategy now these
were some Basics on Google Cloud now as
I said you can always find a lot of
details about pricing about services and
also all the services are accessible in
your free trial account now let me just
walk you through here so one is you
could always find details on
documentation on each of these services
so if I would click on getting started
you have quick start which basically
shows you short tutorials you have
trainings and you have also
certifications now if we click on quick
start now that takes me to this page
which shows me
quick starts or if you would want to
understand about different projects if
you would want to look into the
documentation of creating a Linux
virtual machine or storing a file and
sharing it deploying a container Docker
container image and so on so you have a
lot of quick starts here you can also
look at Cloud minute
on the same page on the right side you
have docs and once you click on that it
takes you to these links now this shows
you build Solutions which shows your top
use cases best practices all the
solutions it's always good to learn from
these use cases which are available and
here you have different feature products
and all the different Services which
Google Cloud offers now you can click on
featured products and that basically
shows you a list of these products now
here we have all the solutions which you
can look at architecture database
Enterprise level big data and Analysis
gaming related internet of things and so
on now if you go down here it shows you
featured products and that shows you
some of the important products such as
compute engine which is belonging to the
compute domain you have Cloud run you
have anthos which is for migration and
basically Cloud adoption when
organizations would want to move from
on-premise to cloud-based Solutions you
have Vision AI you have cloud storage
now that basically allows you to store
any kind of data whether that's an
object so this is acting as an object
storage you have Cloud SQL which is
basically a ready to use service where
you would be using MySQL postgres or any
other SQL Server database Services you
have bigquery which is a data warehouse
which basically allows you to store your
structured data and then you have your
AI and machine learning related products
so you have automl Vision AI video AI
text to speech speech to text and so on
now you also have different platform
accelerators which can be used and in
any of these cases for example if I
would click on compute engine which is a
featured product from Google Cloud now
that shows you basically your quick
starts using your Linux machines how-to
guides which tells you completely
working on a VM instance
or working on storage working on
persistent disks and so on and it shows
you the documentation here now you also
have products and pricing option which
you can see for GCB pricing and you
could straight away go to the pricing
you could be looking at Solutions which
talks about infrastructure modernization
now this is something which
organizations are interested in when
they would want to move from their
on-premise solution to your Google Cloud
now here I can say for example I click
on infrastructure modernization you can
always find some case studies what are
the different solutions we have here
right when you talk about Google Cloud
so you can always click on see Solutions
and you can look at VM migration or sap
Cloud right why Google Cloud what it can
be used for VMware as a service or HPC
that is high performance Computing and
about these services we will learn in
detail later now I can go back on the
same page where I was clicking on the
services so you have quick starts you
have how-to guides you have deep
understanding of different concepts
right and here if I click on all how to
guides so that shows me what are the
different ways in which you can work
with compute engine and working with
different instances although it's quite
exhaustive content but then if you
follow steadily then you can learn a lot
about Google Cloud now here I can just
go back so this is just giving you some
idea on the different products which are
available from Google Cloud looking into
different sections finding right
documentation here right and you can
always look into each one of these in
detail for each product which Google
Cloud offers
now if we scroll down we could see all
the options or all the domains which we
see here right let me just go back
because we got into Solutions now we
have quick starts right and then you can
basically scroll all the way down to
look at Cloud SDK which can be set up on
your Windows machine like I have set it
up on my Windows machine plus when you
use Google console you have a GUI which
I'll show you in couple of minutes and
also a cloud shell where you can use
your command line options to work with
Google Cloud platform you have Cloud
console which is nothing but your GUI to
access your resources now you can also
look at in-depth tutorials pricing and
you have different other options so
let's just click on pricing here and
then we have your price list which
basically gives you details of different
services what are available and what are
the services or what are the prices so
for example if I click on compute engine
right and this shows me the pricing
aspect of compute engine which belongs
to compute domain and here you can see
you have VM instance pricing you have
networking pricing Soul tenant nodes
which are specific to particular
organizations or if organizations would
want to have dedicated nodes you have
GPU based pricing right so General
processing units you have disk and image
pricing and you can click on any of the
links and you can see pricing which also
shows you your different kind of machine
types so here you have different kind of
machine types which says N1 N2 n2d E2
you have memory optimized machine types
you have compute optimized you have
premium images and you can basically
look at all the categories you can look
at disk pricing which involves your
persistent disk pricing for ssds or sdds
what are the kind of images what are the
different network Services right and you
can always look at your machine types
you can choose a particular region right
there is the concept of region and
availability zones here and as per
region you could look at the prices
you can also look at standard prices you
could be looking for what are the free
tier machines if I'm specifically
looking for VM instance pricing I can
click on this one and that takes me to
the VM instance pricing what is the
billing module what is the instance
uptime what is the resource base pricing
and then you can also look at different
kind of discounts such as sustained use
discounts committed use discounts
discounts from preemptable VM instances
and so on and this is how you can be
looking at pricing for all different
resources and you can choose the
resource which you are interested in and
then look for the pricing benchmarks
reservations if you would want to use
and you would want to benefit if you
would want to look at what are the
quotas and limits and so on so please
explore this link and you can find lot
of information when it comes to
technical options looking at different
Google Cloud products which we briefly
discussed when it comes to domains and
what each product can be used for you
can always come back to the main page
where I was showing you different
Services we went into pricing straight
away right now you can always come back
to this page on your cloud.google.com
and then you have your Solutions
which talks about different products
right and you can click on these or you
can look into technical documentation so
this talks about your different featured
Solutions infrastructure Solutions you
have data center migration related and
so on so I could be talking more and
more about Google Cloud platform it's a
ocean it's a huge chunk of different
services for different organizational
requirements so look into this link and
also what you can do is create a account
on Gmail I mean you could create a free
account or you could go to
cloud.google.com and then you could
create a free account like I have
created here and I can just click on
Console now that's my GUI or Google
Cloud console which basically allows me
to work with Google Cloud now there are
a lot of options here by default when
you create an account now in my case on
the top it says it's a free trial
account I have three hundred dollars
credit and out of that 251 dollars is
left and 237 days out of a year are left
for my account now here I can basically
see the project right and by default we
can create an project or by default
there is a project existing for any user
so when you log in it creates a
particular project and you could create
a new project and project would be to
dedicate your different services or
different resources per different
project so this is your dashboard which
basically shows your project which shows
you a project number and a project ID
which is always unique now you can click
on this and this if you would want you
can hide this information you can also
look into the documentation part of it
then it shows you the different services
or a graphical information of services
which you might have used in past so you
have compute engine which shows you how
how much percentage of CPU was used you
can always go to compute engine as a
service you can look at your Google
route platform status and look at the
Google Cloud status now this is billing
now since this shows me the billing
period for April month and I can always
look at detailed charges I can look at
reporting I can look at different apis
which Google offers and for your
different kind of work you can always go
to the API overview or the API link and
enable or disable any API now once you
enable or disable any API then you can
use that so you have new section you
have documentation and you have getting
started guides which tells you how to
work or enable different apis if you
would want to deploy a pre-built
solution at Dynamic logging monitoring
errors deploying a Hello World app and
so on now this is your dashboard I can
click on activity and that that would
show me what kind of activity I would
have done in my cloud platform I can
always choose the kind of activities by
saying activity type I can choose the
resources now it shows me that I created
some VM instances I deleted them I
updated some metadata I basically worked
on instances I changed some firewall
rules here I have then also worked on
some other services or apis so I created
some buckets which is for object storage
and again I have been working with some
instances and creating some firewall
rules here I have granted some
permissions I am setting up a policy
right so this activity gives me a
history of what things I have done over
past couple of months while working on
Google Cloud platform now
on the top left corner you have the
hamburger menu which you can click on
this so that's your navigation menu and
when you click on this this shows you
home it takes you to the marketplace it
specifically takes you to billing you
can always look at apis and services so
here in API Services I can pretty much
go to a dashboard and I can see a report
on the traffic or errors or latency and
the kind of apis which are available so
you have compute engine API you have
bigquery API bigquery data transfer API
bigquery storage cloud data proc so
these are some of the apis or Services
I've used in past might be I was
evaluating a product might be I was
using a particular product so you have
whenever you would want to use a
particular service from Google Cloud
platform you would be enabling these
apis so here we see some apis for data
proc you have logging monitoring you
have have resource manager API you have
Cloud SQL which allows you to directly
use MySQL or postgres you have cloud
storage right and so many apis so if I
would want to enable a particular API
which is not right now required but then
it's good to know you can always click
on this one you can search for an API so
for example if I would say data proc
right and that shows me the cloud data
proc API which manages Hadoop based
clusters and jobs on Google Cloud
platform so I can spin up a Hadoop
cluster and I can start running some
jobs on a Hadoop cluster on demand and
as I'm done with it I can just get rid
of it so this is an API which I would
have to enable and then for every
particular service you also have an
admin API which you would enable
now going back so coming out from this
API Library I got into API and services
now there is you can look into the
library you can look at credentials and
you can also look at different time
intervals for which you can see the
usage of your different apis now going
back to the menu you have support
wherein you can always reach out to the
Google support team if you are using a
paid version even with free trial you
can try to reach out and you will find
someone to help but it is always good
when you have a billing cycle reaching
out the customer care you have identity
access management and admin and this is
required when you're working with
different apis or Services when you
would want to have relevant access you
have getting started you have security
related options you have anthos which is
mainly for migration now here you can
look at your different domains such as
which we discussed so you have of
compute and in compute you have
different services so you have app
engine you have compute engine
kubernetes you have Cloud functions and
Cloud run you can look into the storage
aspect which shows you bit table which
is usually and mainly for your
unstructured data big table which is
something which gave rise to popular
nosql databases like edgebase and
Cassandra you have data store which can
be used you have firestore file store
storage which can be used to put in data
of any kinds you have SQL for structured
data you have spanner as a service you
have memory store and you have data
transfer now when it comes to the
networking domain you have all these
services such as VPC virtual private
network network related services for
your load balancing for using a
cloud-based DNS or Cloud defined Network
you have hybrid connectivity network
service TS security and intelligence
then you have other options for your
operations which can be used and here
you have different other tools which can
be used such as Cloud build you have
Cloud tasks containers registry
deployment manager and many more big
data specific you have the services here
so you have data proc which can be used
to spin up your clusters you have
published subscribe messaging systems
such as now Kafka which you might have
heard of originates its idea from here
so Pub sub you have data flow you have
iot core bigquery which is a real
Warehouse package or data warehousing
solution from Google Cloud now then you
have your artificial intelligence
related Services another Google
Solutions so you can always find a huge
list of services or you can say at high
level Solutions offered by Google cloud
and we can use these to basically test
some of the solutions use them and work
on them so I'll give you a quick demo on
different Services which can be used
here from your Google Cloud platform now
this is your Google Cloud platform and
this is your console now this also gives
you a cloud shell which can be activated
so that you can work from command line
and you can always find a lot of
documentation on that so you can also
set up your Cloud cell that is SDK on
your Windows machine and if you have set
it up then basically you could be doing
something like gcloud right if the cloud
has been set up so in my case I had set
up the cloud SDK and basically I can get
into that by looking at what path I have
set up so Cloud SDK and then I can be
using it from my Windows machine as per
my comfort I can also activate the cloud
shell here which will basically open up
a terminal and at any point of time you
can open up this one Cloud cell in a
different window it is preparing the
cloud shell where it will by default set
up your project it will set up the
metadata and now I am logged into my
Google Cloud account from command line
and here I can basically use gcloud
right and that basically shows you the
different options which are available
which you can be using so if you would
want to use a particular service you can
also try giving a help and that shows
you how do you manage your Google Cloud
platform right so you have different
options for billing to work with your
different services and basically you
could be working on Google Cloud using
this Cloud shell from your command line
usually for people who are learning old
cloud in the beginning it is always good
to go for console and use your different
services from here in an easier way but
as I said you can always use the command
line for example if I would just go
ahead and type gcloud create instances
and that will directly take me to the
cloud console documentation which shows
you different options which you can use
to work with instances so I could do a
gcloud compute instances create and then
I can give my instance name and so on
and I'll show you some examples on that
so you can be using your Cloud console
right that is your Cloud shell and you
can straight away start working from
command line however I would suggest
using console in the beginning and when
you are well experienced then you can
start using Cloud shell to do things
from command line and when you are fully
experienced you can always switch and
certain things are usually useful or
easier when done from command line and
some are easier when you do it from the
console and you can use any one of these
options now we can go to Google Cloud
console now as of now I can close this
one I still have my cloud cell open if I
would want to look into it I can click
on this one and I can straight away go
to compute and engine where I would want
to work on creating some instances on
Google Cloud platform using the compute
engine service and then basically
connecting to those instances and
basically trying out some basic things
so you can click on VM instances and
then once this comes up I can always
create some instances now if you see
here I have some instances already
created right and I can continue working
on those I can create new instances I
can use different options while creating
instances and I'll show you that in a
demo in quick seconds so let's have a
quick demo on setting up gcp instances
now before that let's have a quick recap
so when you talk about instance or a
virtual machine it is hosted on Google's
infrastructure right and you can create
your Google Cloud instance using this
Google Cloud console that is by clicking
on this and then going to compute engine
and clicking on VM instances now you can
also do that from Google Cloud command
line tool that is cloud shell and you
can be doing that using compute engine
API so compute engine instances can run
the public images for Linux or Windows
servers that Google provides you also
have option of creating or using custom
images that you can create and import
from your existing systems you can
deploy Docker containers which are
automatically launched on instance
running containers optimized OS now when
you talk about instances and projects
always remember that in each instance
belongs to a Google Cloud console
project and a project can have one or
more instances
when you talk about instances and
storage options each instance has a
small boot persistent disk which I will
show you in for this queens that
contains the OS you can add more storage
space if needed and when you talk about
instances and network a project can have
up to five VPC networks so VPC network
is virtual private networks wherein you
can virtual private Cloud networks where
you can have your resources within your
own subnet and each instance belongs to
one VPC Network now instances in same
network can communicate with each other
through local area network protocol an
instance uses internet to communicate
within any machine so that could be
virtual physical or outside its own
network when you talk about instances
and containers you should remember that
compute engine instances support a
declarative method for launching your
application using containers now you can
create a VM instance or a VM instance
template you can provide a Docker image
and launch the configuration
so there are different ways in which you
can create these instances and once you
create these instances you can say for
example you're creating a Linux instance
you can associate SSH keys with your
Google account or your G Suite account
and then manage your admin non-admin
access to the instance using IM roles if
you connect to your instance using
gcloud or SSH from console which we will
see later compute engine can generate
SSH keys for you and apply that to your
Google cloud or G Suite account now what
we can do is we can see how we can
create your Google Cloud instances from
your console or from the command line
let's have a look in creating instances
using GCB console now that we have
learned on some basics of Google Cloud
platform what are the different Services
what are different domains basically
looking at your Google Cloud console or
even Cloud Shell let's go ahead and
create some VM instances now that's from
your compute engine service and let's
try connecting to these instances and
see how this works let's also see what
are the different options which are
available when you would want to create
the virtual machine instances here so
when you click on your drop down from
the top left and choose compute engine
so it brings you to this page so I can
show that again so you can click on
compute engine click on VM instances and
that basically brings you to this page
now here it tells you compute engine
lets you use Virtual machines that run
on Google's infrastructure so we can
create micro VMS or large instances
running different distributions of Linux
or Windows using standard images that is
public images and you can also have your
own image so let's create a VM instance
by clicking on create
now that's basically helping me to
create an instance here so it shows me
the instance name I can give it
something so let me say C1 now I can add
labels so what is label it basically
allows you to organize your project add
arbitrary labels as key value pairs to
your resources this so this is basically
categorizing your labels and projects if
you have multiple projects now remember
if you have your Cloud console and if
you have created your free trial account
it will allow you to do these things if
not you may have to go back to the
billing section and see if the billing
is enabled which also means that when
you are creating your Google Cloud
account it will ask you to clean your
credit card details but they do not
charge anything or they might charge
might be one dollar or one rupee
depending on your location and that's
also refunded but that's just to verify
your card now once I've given the name I
can choose a region so I would basically
choose Europe since I'm in Europe I
would be clicking on Europe West 3 and
here I can choose an availability Zone
availability zone is basically to make
your services or instances or any other
resources highly available so you can
choose one of the availability zones now
I would choose save S3 now this one we
can scroll down and here it says machine
configurations you have general purpose
machines you have memory optimized
machines which is M1 series and you can
always go back to the Google Cloud page
and see what a particular kind of
machine specializes in so I would click
on General's purpose and in general
purpose you have different categories so
you have N1 which is powered by Intel
Skylake CPU platform or you have E2
which is CPU platform selected selection
based on availability so let's have N1
selected now this one shows me the
machine type and if you are using your
free tier account then you can start
with correcting a micro machine which is
one virtual CPU core you can go for a G1
small which is one virtual CPU core and
1.7 GB Ram you can even go up to a
high-end machine and then you can
basically see if you are using a free
account how many of these machines you
can use if I would be selecting eight
virtual CPU cores and 32 gigabyte of
memory then it would allow me to create
at least two instances by this
configuration we will use N1 standard
which is one virtual CPU core 3.75 GB
memory now then we can also deploy a
container image to this VM instance if
you would be interested in deploying a
container image let's not get into that
right now here it shows you the port
disk and it shows you dbn gnu 9 Linux 9.
what I would do is I can go for this
distribution or I can choose a Linux
distribution of my child choice so here
you have public images you have custom
images you also have snapshots if you
have created backup of your previous
images here I can choose for example
Ubuntu and then I can choose a
particular version so let's go for
Ubuntu 18.04 you can go for the latest
one also 18.04 would be good enough and
here it tells me what is a boot disk so
you have ssds or you have standard
persistent disks now ssds are little
expensive in comparison to your standard
persistent disks or your sdds but then
ssds are faster so as of now we can
choose standard persistent disk as it is
and we can let the gigabyte be 10 now
depending on your requirement you can
increase this you can even add disks
later that's not a problem click on
select now here I have access Scopes so
here I will say allow default access you
can also set access for each API or you
can give full access to all Cloud apis
so that based on your requirement you
can anytime change later also we will
also say allow HTTP traffic and we can
also choose allow https traffic that
basically allows me to access this
machine or Services which are HTTP based
accessible from this machine now I can
just click on create however it would be
good to basically enable connectivity to
this machine now we can do that in
different ways one is when you bring up
your machine it will have an SSH access
which you can log in from the cloud
platform here itself or what you can do
is you can create a private and a public
key using some softwares like putty or
puttygen so for example if you do not
have that on your machine you can
download you can just type in download
putty that takes you to the putty.org
page and here you can click on download
putty and scroll down which shows you
for your 64-bit machine which I have in
my case you can download putty.exe which
is basically your SSH internet client to
connect to your machines you can also
use putty gen which will be allowing you
to create a private and a public key
which I have done in my case let me show
you how so what you can do is you can go
to puttygen to begin with and here you
can click on generate now then to have
this key generated just move your cursor
on the top here in the empty space and
that creates your key you can give it a
name so for example let's give a
username I would give hdu now I can give
a password for this one so let me give a
simple password
and what I can also do is I can copy
this public key from here and for my
later usage I can just keep it in my
notepad file which I can use later and
I'll show you when so now we can save
this private key and this will basically
allow me to save my private key I can
choose desktop and I can give it a name
so let's say new key new key and that
will be getting saved in a DOT PPK file
so let's save it and that's done so we
also have our public key and we have
saved our private key now we know that
when you would want to connect using SSH
you need your private keys to the client
and public key also has to be existing
so let's take this public key so let's
do a control a I'm going to copy this
and I'm going to come back to my Google
Cloud console and here you can click on
security so you can click on the
security tab here here scroll down and
just give your public key once you give
that it resolves and shows you the name
and this is good enough so that I can
use my SSH client to connect to this
machine I can click on Create and this
will basically create my VM instance it
will take some time and then your
instance will have an internal IP which
will show up here external IP and it
will also show you options to connect to
these machines so this is my internal IP
this is my external IB which I can use
to connect from a client I can easily
connect from the option here which says
SSH and I can say open in a browser
window I can even open this in a custom
Port I can look at the gcloud command
which you can give from cloud shell or
you can use another SSH so let's first
do a open in browser window and let's
see if this connects so we can easily
connect to our instance the Ubuntu 18
instance which I just set up here easily
in couple of seconds now this is trying
to establish a connection using your SSH
keys and when you do that it also
basically brings up this web browser so
I'm already connected it shows my
username which is my cloud account
username and I have been connected to
this machine here using SSH it did not
ask me for any password and basically
now I can just check what do I have in
my Linux file system right and I can
anytime login as root by doing a sudo Su
for example let's try installing a
package and I can say aptkit install
whim or app get install wget or aptkit
install open SSH and all these packages
are already existing so not an issue now
I can start using this instance I can
just look at the disk what is available
okay now we gave an 10 gigabyte out of
which we see 8.3 gigabyte here for the
dev sda1 and then 1.8 gigabyte available
and you can continue using this machine
this was the easiest way of connecting
to a VM instance using SSH
now what we can also do is I can just
leave this and I will now try to connect
using an external SSH client right and
here you can copy the public IP so when
you want to connect to an instance you
will have to get the public IP also
remember that if you select and stop
this machine which will stop your
billing counter and if you start it
again the internal IP will remain same
but the external IP is the one which
will change
I can obviously select this machine
anytime and I can do a cleanup and I can
delete it I can do a start of the
machine if it is stopped and I can even
import the virtual machine to be used
later so there are different options
which you can always use so this is my
instance and if you would want to look
at the details click on this one C1 and
that should basically allow you to look
at the details so it shows you what is
the instance ID what is the machine type
is it reservation specific what is the
CPU platform what's the zone and all the
other details
at any point of time if you would want
to edit you can always click on edit and
you can change the details as you need
now you can also look at the equivalent
rest command to basically use the rest
API to connect to this instance for now
I have copied the public IP and I would
want to connect it using putty so let's
go in here and let's give the hostname
so I can give Ubuntu I can give my IP
address so that's in my session now I
will click on SSH I would go into
authentication I'll click on browse and
this is where I need to choose the PPK
file so this is the one which we created
new key let's select this
and then I can come back to session I
can even save this and I can call it as
my instance one let's save it and you
can create any number of instances so
you see I have created different
instances here for my Google cloud or
Amazon related instances and I can click
on open it says the service host key is
not cached in the registry that's fine
just click on yes
and basically it says no authentication
method supported now this could be
because we have not enabled your SSH
access so let's look at that so now
let's see if we were trying to connect
using putty what was the issue here so
if I go back to my putty select my
instance load it it says Port 22 I am
giving the username which is Ubuntu or
sorry that's the wrong username we gave
and that might be the reason we had set
up the user as sdu so let's save this
again and now let's try connecting to
this one and it asks for my password and
you are able to connect this right now
if there was any other issue related to
network connectivity then we could look
at the rules the inbound and outbound
rules which allow us to look into the
machine now we are connected to our
machine here using hdu user I can log in
as root and I can continue working so
not only from the SSH within the cloud
console but you can use an external SSH
client and connect to your machine so
this is your Ubuntu machine and we can
basically look at the space and that
basically confirms we are connecting to
the same machine which shows 8.3
gigabytes here and 1.8 gigabytes here
which we were seeing from the ssh in the
browser now let's close this and let's
go back to our instance page now here
you can always look at the network
details and this will show you your
different kind of rules that is ingress
or egress rules which basically allows
to connect to this machine from an
external network or for this machine to
connect to an external network so here
we have different firewall rules which
shows default allow HTTP that's your
Ingress Rule and it tells you apply to
all it shows me what are the IP ranges
where I can specifically give the ipf my
machine it shows the protocols it shows
what are the different ports which you
have used for these services for example
RDP or SSH which shows 22 you have icmp
HTTP and https now anytime if you would
want to make a change to these rules
that can be done by going into your
network details and say for example you
would want to work on firewall rules so
we have these firewall rules here you
can click on this one so right now we
are looking into the network domain and
we are looking into VPC Network right
and this shows me what are the different
rules we have now if I would want to
create a different firewall rule for a
different protocol I can always click on
create firewall rule I can give it a
name okay I can say what if you would
want to turn on the firewall logs you
can basically say what is the kind of
traffic so Ingress applies to incoming
traffic and egress applies to outgoing
traffic and you can then basically
choose what are the IP ranges from where
you want that connection to be coming in
or to going out you can choose a
particular protocol you can give a
protocol here with comma separated
values and you can create a firewall
rule so this might be required depending
on the services which you are running
wherein you might want to enable your
access to your machine from an external
service or to an external service so you
can always go to network details from
here you can then go into firewall rules
create a firewall rule apply that to
your instance and restart your instance
so as of now we don't need to create any
network details here because my Ingress
or egress rules are already available
right now I can basically then have my
instance stopped and removed so I can
just do a stop or since this is running
the ideal wave would be to do a stop I
could also do a reset now what does
reset do reset does not basically delete
the machine what it does is it does a
cleanup of the machine and it brings it
to the initial state so sometimes we
might have installed certain things on
our machine we would want to clean them
up and at that time reset can be useful
I can basically click on delete right
and I can select this and I can way
clean up and this is good always when
you are using a free trial account try
to use different Services play around
with them and then you can clean up so
that you do not waste your free billing
credit right and you can use it for
Meaningful stuff now I have clicked on
delete and within few seconds my
instance which I had created will be
deleted also to remember is if you are
creating multiple instances then you can
connect from one machine to other
machine using SSH by using the private
file so for that we can learn in detail
later so this is just a simple example
of using your compute engine creating
your instances connecting to it from an
internal SSH or from an external SSH
client such as putty where you have
already created your private and public
Keys now I can click on the browser here
and then I can basically come out and I
can basically be looking into any
particular service so we just looked
into compute engine right you have
different other options you have
instance groups you have instance
templates for example let's click on
instance templates here and that
basically shows you that you don't have
any instance template and this basically
facilitates say for example you are
working as a admin and you would want to
create an instance template so that
using that you can describe a VM
instance and then you can basically use
this template to create different
instances you can go for soul tenant
nodes you can look for machine images
you can also look at your disks you can
create a snapshots and you can look at
different options here now let's come
back here and let's click on home and
that should take you back to your home
page which basically shows you if a
particular API which you have used
recently which shows me in the graph
here so I can go to the api's overview
right and that basically shows me if
there were any errors if I was using the
compute engine API to basically create a
VM instance and that's why we were
seeing some spike in the graph so this
is a quick demo of using your compute
engine service provided by Google Cloud
wherein you can create VM instances and
use those VM instances for your
application installation for any other
purpose now that we have seen how you
use your Cloud console to create an
instance and also clean it up let's also
understand how you can do using your
command line options and let's see what
it takes or what are the different
commands which you can use to create
your instances
now you can always when when you're
creating an instance you can use compute
engine which Provisions resources to
start the instance so instance basically
has different states which we can see
when we are creating the instance so you
basically start the instance instance
moves into staging that is prepared for
your first boot finally it boots up and
then it moves into running so when you
look at instant states which we will
create instance in C it will basically
have different states such as
provisioning where resources are being
allocated for instance but instances not
yet running then it goes into staging
where resources have been acquired and
instance is being prepared for your
first boot then instance is booting up
and running and if you are stopping an
instance it goes into being stop status
and it would be moved to the terminated
option you can also do a repairing of
instance and finally you can terminate
your instance or clean it up by stopping
and then deleting it now when you say
stopping and resetting an instance you
can stop the instance as I showed
earlier if you no longer need it but if
you need for future use you can just use
the reset option which will basically
wipe the content tense of instance or
any application State and then finally
you can stop it and have it terminated
now when you would want to do that using
your Cloud console or we have seen the
options now let's also see from the
command line tool how you can do it so
here I have the cloud cell which I
brought up from here and I basically
opened it in a new window so command
line tool enables you to easily manage
your compute engine resources in a
friendlier format than using your
compute engine API now gcloud which is
part of cloud SDK is the main command
here and then you can always auto
complete the different options here so
when you would want to create or work on
gcloud you can just type in gcloud here
and then for example I could just say
help to see different options of gcloud
which will show me the different options
which you can use here now we would be
interested in compute instances so I
could also do a gcloud compute
compute instances and then I can
basically say create and then I can do a
help now that should show me different
options which work with gcloud compute
instances create command which is
expecting an instance name so your
Google Cloud SDK which we can set up on
our Windows machine or even on your
Linux machine a set of tools that helps
you to manage resources and applications
hosted on your gcp that is your Google
Cloud platform now here you have options
such as gcloud which I'm showing you
right now you have Gs util and then you
have BQ so that also can be used so you
can set up a Google Cloud compute if
using gcloud now what we can do is if we
are setting up our SDK on our Windows
machine then we would have to do a
gcloud init which basically initializes
your configurations for GE cloud
now here we are using a cloud shell
which was started from the console and
we don't have to basically give your
gcloud init command because it's already
initialized now you can always look at
your default Zone you can look at your
region what is being used all those
things are coming from the metadata
which is being used so for example I
could be looking at the metadata for my
particular project by just doing a g
cloud and then I can say compute and I
would be interested in Project info so I
can just do a project minus info and
then I can do it describe and then I
need my project ID so I can say minus
minus project and I can get my project
ID from here so you can click on this
one and that's my project ID so I can
click click on this one and here I can
just do a right click and if it does not
paste then you can do a control V and
then I can try to look at my project
info so this basically will give me the
metadata which is by default set and we
can always look at what are the regions
or what is the Zone which has been set
so if it has been set so I'm looking at
my details it is showing me my SSH keys
and then it can be using your default
region and your default available zones
it also shows my username and other
details so this is basically to look at
the metadata which is available now at
any point of time I can basically say
add metadata I can basically choose
metadata option and I can say my default
region should be Europe which I was
choosing earlier so I can just bring up
this command again and what I can do is
I can say here where I have gcloud
compute project info where I did a
describe earlier now what I can also do
is I can just say add metadata
and then I can specify what is the
metadata I would be interested in adding
I can then say Google compute
default
region and then I can basically give a
region for example Europe and then I can
say West 3
and if you are not well experienced you
can always do it from console or you can
be doing it from here so I'm giving
Google Cloud compute Google compute
default region then I can also give a
Google compute default Zone
and then I can pass in a value for
default zone so I can say Europe West 3
and then basically I can give an
availability zone so if it is basically
giving me some error where I'm trying to
pass in these values so I can just give
it this way and then it basically says
that if you can look into particular
help to see what is the command which
you would have to do now I can basically
do a g Cloud init here initial
configuration and this basically says
that it is initializing my default
configuration it says re-initialize this
configuration from cloud shell you want
to create a new configuration so if I
had updated my metadata then basically I
could just do a cloud in it and I could
be re-initializing my default
configuration or properties which I have
passed constant so as of now I will not
activate or change the default region
let's go for a simple way in which you
can create your compute engine so for
example I'll just say one and it is
reinitializing it asks me what is the
username and let's select that it says
what is the project and let's select
that and do you want to configure a
default compute region and zone right
and I will just say Yes And basically
then it shows me different options which
we have here so there are too many
options here and then here we were
interested in Europe West 3 so let's
choose 21 right and then that basically
allows me to choose my region and my
zone so it also gives you some
specification so it says your project
default compute Zone has been set to
Europe West 3A you can change it by
running gcloud config set and you can
give a compute zone right so I can
always give these commands I can get
help information here so I can just say
gcloud config set and I can be
specifying the compute zone so I can say
compute slash Zone and I can give a Zone
I can say compute slash region and I can
give a region name if I would want to do
it or the easier ways like what I did
right now so you can basically do a
command gcloud in it and then basically
it allows you to to change your
configuration or set default things here
you can all the times you can say gcloud
config unset to basically remove a
compute zone or a compute region now
there are different ways so if you were
working on a Linux machine you could
always use an export command something
like this so you could do export compute
sorry Cloud SDK and then you can say
compute underscore Zone and then give
your Zone name or compute underscore
region and give your region or you could
add it in your bash RC file right now
that is when you have your Cloud SDK set
up on your Linux machine or on Windows
machine and you would want to
specifically set a Zone and a region for
all your compute related resources so we
don't need to do that the default
settings are already given here right
and what we can do is we can start by
quickly looking into gcloud compute
instances options so I can say gcloud
compute instances and then I can just do
a list at any point of time if you would
need help you can just do a gcloud
compute and then say minus minus help or
I could just do a gcloud compute and
that shows me different options which I
have here from which I use instances I
can always type instances and again hit
enter and it shows me different options
what you would want to do so I can
initially just type list which should
show me what are the list or what are
the instances available and as of now we
don't have any instances I can always do
a list and then I can specify minus
minus format and then try to get the
information in a Json format or EML or
minus minus format text
so you can always do a list you can do a
filter so there are different options
with your list and you can you can try
doing a help here and that basically
shows you what are the options so for
example if I do a help and it shows me
with list what are the things you can do
so you can give a name you can give a
regular expression you can say in
particular Zone you can use a minus
filter so there are different commands
which are available and you can always
find all those options here as I showed
you earlier so now what we would be
interested in is basically going for
your compute instances I can always do a
SSH and I can create an instance I can
add and remove metadata right for my
instances by giving a particular Zone by
giving a particular region and if you
would want to do that now here what we
can do is we can can basically create an
instance by just giving a name to that
particular instance and we can then go
back to our console and see what has it
done so I can say here create so that's
an option let's see what does the create
do so it says okay you are giving a
create option but you would have to give
a name so let's say let's call it E1 and
that will be the name of my instance and
this one is an easy command from your
Cloud cell which basically creates an
instance you see the Zone which has been
set it is the standard machine type it
is not preemptable it has an internal IP
and it has an external IP now I have
created an instance and here I can just
go back and then I can just do a Refresh
on this page and that already shows me
the instance which I have created and
then you can use the same method to
connect to it using an SSH so I have an
instance created from my cloud shell and
what I can do is I can basically look
into instances and see what are the
different options with instance so if we
did a create right you have an option
delete we did a create you have an
option delete you can be then deleting
the instance from the command line or
you can use other options so you can do
a list you can do a stop you can start
so I can basically do a stop and let's
say even let's go ahead and do a stop
commands are pretty easy here to
remember or you can always use the help
option and now I'm trying to stop the
instance and then basically I can go
ahead and delete it so this is a simple
way where I created a instance from the
command line or from the console which I
showed earlier and similarly you can be
working with other options so now I have
created stop the instance let's do a
listing to see if my instance shows up
it shows up right and it says the status
is terminated so you have stopped it
it's in the terminated status and now
what I can do is I can go ahead and
delete it
so it says this will be lost are you
sure you would want to continue just say
yes and that should take care of
deleting your instance
so this is a quick demo on creating your
instance we have already seen how you
can connect to these instances using SSH
now that we have created instances let's
also see how to use Google Cloud's
storage service which can be used to
load data or upload data so for this we
will have to look into your Google cloud
storage options and here you can look in
cloud storage so let's go back here on
the top which shows me different
Services which we have here and let's
look into storage so this one shows me
your storage option now you can click on
browser and that basically shows me your
storage browser which shows me on the
top you have options for creating a
bucket now Google Cloud Storage allows
you to store any kind of data here the
easiest and the simplest way would be by
using Cloud console although you can
again use cloud shell and in that you
can use your GS util command and GS util
basically has different options where
you can be using say for example I would
want to work on buckets so I can be
using MB and then I can use my command
line option to create buckets I can put
in data there I can browse it and I can
access the data from command line so
let's create a bucket here let's click
on this let's give it a name so let's
say my data important that's the name
now I can click on continue straight
away I can look into all of these
options if I'm interested in so you can
basically be looking at your monthly
cost estimate in the beginning now I can
click on continue or you can say choose
where to store your data and this one
shows you different options so you have
region specific click
so let's also give the bucket name with
all lower case that's what is required
yeah so coming back to the location type
you can choose multi-region which
basically allows High availability so
your bucket or your storage option will
be accessible across regions
you can also give dual region and high
availability and low latency across two
regions I can also say region specific
so for our use case we can just give
region specific which can keep our cost
low but in business use cases you would
be going for multi-region now here you
have location and I would again go for
say Europe and let's choose Europe
Wesley Frankfurt it is always a good
practice that when you create your
instances when you create your storage
or you use different Services try to
have a geographical region Chosen and
then you would try to put things on your
services within the particular region
within a particular Zone unless you
would want to make it accessible and
available across regions
now I can then choose a default storage
class so when you say default storage
class there are different storage class
and each one is for a different use case
so you have standard which is best for
short-term storage and frequently
accessed data you have near line so this
is basically best for backups and data
access less than once a month you can
also have code lines so these are
basically like your cold storage or
freezing storage which you might have
heard generically as terms so you can
choose one of these storage classes
depending on what will be the use case
for this particular storage bucket so
let it be standard now how to control
access to objects so you can basically
say specify access to individual objects
by using object level permissions now
you can give permissions to the bucket
you can just say uniform access to all
objects in the bucket by using only
Bucket Level permissions so you can
choose that you can also go into
advanced settings and here you can see
different ways in which you can have
configuration set up now you can also
have a retention policy to specify the
minimum duration where that this
bucket's object must be protected from
deletion and you can set a retention
policy will not get into all that we
will just first try creating a bucket so
just click on Create and that should
create your bucket wherein I have my
bucket now I can click on overview to
see the details what is the region which
region it belongs what is the storage
class anytime you can always click on
edit bucket and make some changes here
you can look at the permissions so
bucket users fine grained access
allowing you to specify access to
individual objects and then you can
basically look at who has access to this
so in my case editors of the project
they basically are the bucket owners
owners of project viewers of the project
right and you can basically choose what
kind of access you need so for this you
can always go into cloud storage and
then you can decide what kind of access
you would want to give whether that's a
storage admin it's an object admin
object Creator object viewer and so on
you can always look at storage Legacy
and for any other services depending on
what apis you have enabled right you can
always control your permissions so right
now it is storage Legacy bucket reader
and that's fine and this one is bucket
owner and then might be I was using some
other services like data proc which uses
cloud storage and that's why I have
given data's proc service agent also so
these are some of the members you can
remove you can view by specific members
you can view by roles so what are the
different roles which have access to
this so it says storage Legacy bucket
owner there are two owners based on this
particular project so these are Auto
controlled but then you can add or
remove machines you can save storage
cost by adding a life cycle rule to
delete objects after the duration of
current retention policy so you can add
different policies and you can basically
control your bucket now my bucket is
already created right so so I can go
back and then I see my bucket is already
here I can click on this option and you
can anytime edit the bucket permissions
you can edit the labels the default
storage class you can just go ahead and
delete the bucket you can export it to
Cloud Pub sub so basically if you would
want to have the content from this
bucket being accessible in a message
queuing system you can go for Pub sub
you can process with Cloud functions and
you can scan with cloud data loss
prevention so there are different
options which are available we can
always select this bucket and delete it
now I can click on the bucket and that
basically shows me different ways in
which I can upload some data here so I
can just click on upload files and here
then I can choose some files so for
example I'll go in here I'll go into
data sets and I have different data sets
so for example let's choose this one
which is a CSV file and then I'm just
uploading this to my storage right it's
as simple as this so you can drag and
drop your files or you can just upload
your files and my file is uploaded here
now I can basically edit permissions for
this one right so this is in the bucket
so anyone who has access to this bucket
can basically download this file it can
they can copy move or rename this you
can export it and you can look at the
permissions of this file so let's look
at edit permissions and it says
for this project whoever is the owner it
has access I've also given a specific
user my Gmail ID and I've given access
so at any point of time you can just say
add item and then you can start giving
different kind of accesses so let's
click on cancel here now my data is
already uploaded into this particular
bucket and that's a simple usage of your
cloud storage now what we can also do is
I can basically select this and I can
delete it I can also create specific
folders and then basically load data
into it I can click on this one I can
just do a download and then I can
download it anywhere on my machine so
let's go to desktop and let's download
this file so we not only uploaded some
content in the bucket but we also
downloaded that in a different location
which will be accessible now what I
could have also done is I could have
created a folder here and I could have
specified say for example immediate
immediate data
okay and I'm clicking on this one so
that's my immediate data I can click on
this one and now I can upload my data
specifically to this particular folder
by using the same mechanism you can just
do upload file let's choose air
passengers let's say open and my file
will be uploaded so you can always
choose what is the retention expiry date
for this one so as of now there is
nothing right but you can be deleted
objects can be deleted or modified until
there is a minimum duration you can
control all of that you can basically
download it right you can copy it and
you can move it and rename it so this is
a simple example where I created a
particular bucket right now if for
example you click on this transfer so it
says cloud storage data transfer
products have moved you can now find
storage transfer service on-premise data
and transfer Appliance in new data
transfer section right so you can always
go back
to cloud storage you can also look at
transfer options which are mainly when
you are using your on-premise service
and you would want to upload data in a
Google Cloud right so this is my bucket
here now I can go to Cloud console and
here what I can do is if I would be
interested in working so I can just say
GS util right and then we have for
example let's try a help okay and that
basically shows me my GS util now you
can always go to Quick Start gsutil tool
and this is one more way wherein
basically you can do it from the command
line so working with buckets so you can
do a GS util MB minus B and then on a
particular Zone if you would be
interested in and then you can say GS
colon and give a name so my awesome
bucket this is how you will create a
bucket which will show you it is
creating a bucket and then basically you
can upload an image or some data from
internet you can just do a w get
download the file and then you can just
do a GS util copy command and that
basically will pick up the file from
your Cloud shell location put it in your
bucket once you have done that you can
always do a copy right so here you are
doing a copy from your local machine
that is your Cloud cell machine to your
bucket and you can do the reverse of
that that is you can do a copy and you
can point your bucket and the file and
download it to your desktops so you can
just download that using the command
line and you can copy the object to a
folder in the bucket so that is by
creating a particular folder and you are
pushing the file into a particular
bucket you can list the contents of a
bucket using LS and then give your
bucket name so GS colon so we can just
try this one to be simple and rest you
guys can try so so here you can just do
a GS util you can do a LS GS colon slash
slash and then I need to give my bucket
name so in my case the bucket name was
my data important so let's try that so
let's save my data important and I'm
trying to list the bucket and the
content it has right and then you have a
folder and then you can look into the
folder and look into the files so this
is a simple quick option wherein you can
use your Cloud cell you could be using
your Google Cloud SDK from your local
machine or you can be using Cloud
console to create a bucket upload some
data on it download the data see if the
data is accessible and that basically
shows you the power of cloud storage
where you can easily upload any kind of
data now what we can also do is as
you're using a free account or even a
paid account unless and until you would
want to keep the bucket you can select
it and you can just go ahead and delete
it so this will basically ask you to key
in the bucket name and let's say my data
important you need to confirm your
bucket name click on confirm and you
could have done that using gsutil and a
delete command from the command line
that is from cloud cell so we have now
created a bucket we have uploaded some
data into it we saw how you can download
it or create a folder and upload some
specific data into it and also you can
do the same thing using GS util tools
wherein you can list your bucket create
your buckets delete it create some
folders into it and do everything from
the command line so this is in simple
way you can use your gcp where either
you can spin up your machines or you can
use cloud storage to basically use a
storage or a easy to use instance on
Google Cloud platform so if you are
ready to embark on this exciting career
path look no further than simply learn
scaltac post graduate program in cloud
computing this comprehensive program
will equip you with the knowledge and
skills needed to navigate the cloud
landscape with confidence dive deep into
Cloud architecture deployment models
security and migration strategies
explore platforms like Amazon web
services Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform to build your Cloud
expertise don't miss out on this chance
to transform your career and join the
ranks of successful Cloud professionals
click the link in the description box
below to discover more about the cloud
computing Basics course to know more
about this course click on the link
mentioned in the description box below
the cloud is much more than just a
reliable storage solution in the year
2021 like the year before proved to be a
watershed even for cloud computing
it gave businesses more freedom to
operate in the face of covert 19.
cloud computing according to it experts
will be at the Forefront of all
Technologies used to address key
businesses concerns in the coming years
cloud computing has generated more
anticipation excitement and investment
than any other it area in the last
decade according to IDC the cloud will
increase at a rate of 22 next year with
the market value of 277 billion dollars
as a result there will surely be a
significant demand for cloud
professionals therefore a right
certification in cloud computing can
help you earn a handsome salary of 145
000 to 227 000 in the United States and
close to 16 lakh to 24 lakh rupees in
India
so let's have a look at the top 10
certification in cloud computing
the first one is AWS certified Solutions
architect associate
AWS certified Solutions architect
associate is a set of technical
certifications offered by Amazon web
services for beginners and professionals
working in Enterprise architecture and
solutions architecture
this certificate AIDS in the
identification and development of
personnel with crucial capabilities for
cloud implementation
AWS certified solution architect
associate certification verifies your
competence to build and deploy
distributed systems on AWS
so this certification is for persons who
can do solution architecture such as
deploying and securing web applications
and who have worked with AWS services
for at least a year
and its difficulty level is easy
skills required for this certification
is understanding of specific programming
or scripting languages like Java python
C hash and many other programming
language available data storage
fundamentals networking
AWS server selection Cloud specific
patterns and Technologies
moving on here are a few certification
details you will need to proceed with
its examination
cost of examination is 150 USD
and the average annual salary is 130
883 dollars
the duration of this examination is 130
minutes with number of questions 65.
you have multiple choice and multiple
response questions
and the passing score is 70 percent
and the granule time of the
certification is two years
the company is hiring our Amazon IBM
capgemini mine tree and ikvia these are
the top companies that hire
second is AWS certified Cloud
practitioner
the AWS certified Cloud practitioner
certification is a foundational level
test designed for people who can
successfully show an overall
understanding of the AWS Cloud according
to Amazon
this exam verifies a candidate's
understanding of essential Cloud
infrastructure and Architectural
Concepts as well as key AWS services
the certification provides an overview
of AWS key Services as well as security
and Network
so this is the idle search Cloud
certification for beginners or anyone
interested in learning more about cloud
computing and the AWS Cloud platform
so the difficulty level is easy
the skills required for this
certification is
oversight on creating architecture for
AWS platform ability to deploy AWS
Solutions and applications building
Cloud Solutions
developing plans for the adoption of
cloud Solutions management and
monitoring of cloud platforms
moving on here are a few certification
details you will need to proceed with
this examination
the cost of examination is 100 USD
average annual salary is 113 932 dollars
examination duration is 90 minutes
number of questions is 65
types of questions are multiple choice
and multiple response question
passing score 70 percent and again the
renewable time for the certification is
two years
and the famous company hiring our Amazon
net app essential Deloitte and solial
LLC
moving on third is AWS certified
developer associate
AWS certified developer associate is an
Amazon web service examination that
measures a person's ability to
successfully demonstrate deploying and
maintaining applications on the AWS
platform
this is the ideal Cloud certification
for programmers and software developers
interested in building Cloud native
applications and the difficulty level is
intermediate
skills required for this certifications
are use the AWS Services API CLI and
software development kits to write
applications
identify key features of AWS Services
understand the AWS shared responsibility
model use a continuous integration of
continuous delivery pipeline to deploy
application on AWS and use and interact
with AWS services
so here are the few certification
details
cost of examination is 150 USD
average annual salary is 130 272 dollars
exam duration is 130 minutes number of
questions is 65. type of questions
multiple choice and multiple response
questions
the passing score is 70 renewable time
is 2 years
and the company hiring at Amazon IBM
capgemini TCS and Oracle
fourth is AWS certified
system operation administrator associate
the AWS certified
sysops administrator associate
certification is designed to demonstrate
technical skills for system
administrators in Cloud operations jobs
this certificate assist organizations in
identifying and developing personnel
with crucial abilities for cloud
implementation
the ability to develop manage and
operate workloads on AWS is demonstrated
by earning the certification
this associate certification is for
professionals who have at least one year
of experience with AWS deployment
management and operations it teaches you
how to identify the right service for
your needs and the difficulty level is
intermediate
so these are the skills required for the
certification understanding of AWS
tenants
hands-on experience with the AWS CLI and
sdks tools understanding of Network
Technologies understanding of security
concept with hands-on experience in
implementing security controls and
compliance requirements understanding of
virtualization technology
moving on here are a few important
details related to this certification
so cost of examination is 150 USD
average annual salary is
966 dollars
the duration of examination is 130
minutes and the number of questions is
which are multiple choice and multiple
response questions
with passing score of 70 and renewal
time of 2 years
and your other companies hiring
Amazon IBM capgemini TCS and Oracle
fifth is Microsoft certified Azure
fundamentals
Azure fundamental certifications allows
you to demonstrate your understanding of
cloud Concepts Azure Services Azure
workloads Azure security and privacy and
Azure pricing in support
the Azure Foundation certification
intended for people who already have a
basic understanding of cloud services it
will explain you Cloud Concepts as well
as how to use them and the difficulty
level is easy
skills required for this certification
is the different cloud computing
Concepts
main Azure Services describing Azure
security private privacy compliance and
Trust
Azure pricing and support
and here are a few certification details
required for the certification
cost of examination is 99 USD which can
vary
average annual salary is 110 000 dollars
the duration of this examination is 85
minutes
and the number of questions varies
between 40 to 60. and the type of
questions are multiple choice and
multiple response questions
the passing score for this examination
is 70 and the renewable time is 6 months
and the top companies hiring are
Microsoft Dell essential and cognizant
sixth is Microsoft certified Azure
administrator associate
and Azure administrator is in charge of
deploying monitoring and managing
Microsoft Azure Solutions which includes
significant compute storage Network and
Security Services
we're earning these this certification
you will be able to demonstrate that you
can deploy and manage Azure compute
resources
this certificate will prepare you to
develop administer and monitor cloud
services such as Storage security and
virtual environments among other things
and the difficulty level is intermediate
so the skills needed for this
certification is
mean Azure services
describing Azure security private and
compliance and Trust
knowledge of azure pricing and support
a knowledge of different cloud computing
Concepts
and here are the further important
details needed for the certification
cost of examination is 165 USD average
annual salary is 107 683 dollars
exam duration is 120 Minutes with number
of questions
varying between 40 to 60.
and the type of questions are multiple
choice and multiple response questions
with the passing score of 70 percent
renewal time is six months and the top
companies hiring are Microsoft Accenture
TCS and Yahoo
seventh is Google associate Cloud
engineer
an associate Cloud engineer delivers and
protects applications
and infrastructure oversees various
projects operations and maintains
corporate solution to ensure that the
fulfilled performance goals
this person has worked with both public
clouds and on-premises systems
for programmers developers and software
Engineers this is the greatest Google
Cloud certification its Holder will be
responsible for deploying web
applications in the cloud as well as
monitoring and managing operations and
the difficulty level is intermediate
here are the some important skills
required for you to excel this
certification basic understanding of
Google Cloud platforms products and
services and basic understanding of
cloud Concepts such as virtual machines
containers and networking
and these are the few important
certification details that you need to
take care of cost of examination is 125
USD with average annual salary of 109
415 dollar
exam duration is 120 Minutes with number
of questions 50.
and the type of questions are multiple
choice and multiple response questions
with a passing score of 70 percent
and the renewable time is two years and
the top companies hiring a Google
Goldman Sachs
here comes the eighth one that is
Microsoft certified Azure solution
architecture expert
to implement Solutions and Azure
solution architect work
with Cloud administrators
cloud dbas and clients
these this credential displays the
ability to provide advice to
stakeholders and translate business
requirements into safe scalable and
dependable Solutions
this certificate is for experienced
programmers developers and devops
Engineers who wish to become Azure
professionals
this is the ideal Cloud certification
and the difficulty level is hard
and these are the skills required for
this Advanced certification
deploying and configuring infrastructure
implementing workloads and security
creating and deploying apps implementing
authentication and securing data
developing for the cloud and for the
Azure storage
and these are the details you need to
remember
cost of examination
165 USD
average annual salary
135 thousand dollars with exam duration
of 150 minutes
and number of questions varies between
40 to 60.
type of questions are multiple choice
and multiple response questions with the
passing score of 70 percent
and the renewal time is six months
and the company's hiring are IBM
Microsoft Infosys and Medline
coming to the ninth one is Google
professional Cloud architect
a Google Certified professional Cloud
architect means you demonstrate the
ability to design and plan A Cloud
solution architecture
manage and provision the Cloud solution
infrastructure
designed for security and compliance
the professional Cloud architect exam
measures your abilities to design and
plan A Cloud solution architecture
managing provision Cloud solution
infrastructure and design for security
and compliance
this is the idle Google Cloud
certification for experience IIT
professionals interested in becoming
solution architects for Google Cloud
technology such as bigtable bigquery and
other GCB platform services and the
difficulty level is hard
and these are the skills you need to
focus on
proficiency with command command line
Linux operating system and system
operations
and three plus years of Industry
experience
and here are the further details you
need to take care of
cost of examination is 200 USD with
average annual salary of 140 000 dollars
the examination duration is 120 Minutes
with number of questions 40 the type of
questions are multiple choice and
multiple response questions but the
passing score of 70 percent
and the renewable time is two years
and the company is hiring are Google and
golden sets
and here comes the last but not the
least 10th certification that is AWS
architect professional
the AWS certified Solutions architect
professional exam verifies Advanced
technical knowledge and experience in
designing distributed applications and
systems on the Amazon web services
platform
this certification AIDS in the
identification and development of
personnel with crucial capabilities for
cloud implementation
the AWS certified Solutions architect
Prudential verifies ability to develop
Implement and evaluate applications on
AWS under a variety of conditions
this Advanced certification teaches you
how to create and deploy scalable web
applications on Amazon AWS servers as
well as how to choose the right service
and power for your application and the
difficulty level is hard
and the skills required for this
certification is
familiarity with AWS CLI AWS apis AWS
cloud formation templates
and windows and Linux environments
ability to provide best practice
guidance on the architectural design
across multiple applications and
projects of the Enterprise
ability to evaluate Cloud application
requirements and ability to design a
hybrid architecture using key AWS
Technologies
and here are the details you need to
know before applying for the exam
cost of examination is 300 USD with
average annual salary of 118 266 dollars
the examination duration is 180 minutes
with number of questions 75.
types of questions are multiple choice
and multiple response questions
with the passing score of 70 percent
and the renewable time is 2 years
and the top companies hiring are Amazon
Central IBM and mindtree
so this was all about top 10 Cloud
certification so if you are ready to
embark on this exciting career path look
no further than simply learn skal Tech
postgraduate program in cloud computing
this comprehensive program will equip
you with the knowledge and skills needed
to navigate the cloud landscape with
confidence dive deep into Cloud
architecture deployment models security
and migration strategies explore
platforms like Amazon web services
Microsoft Azure and Google Cloud
platform to build your Cloud expertise
don't miss out on this chance to
transform your career and join the ranks
of successful Cloud professionals click
the link in the description box below to
discover more about the cloud computing
Basics course to know more about this
course click on the link mentioned in
the description box below
let's have a look at some of the skills
required to become a cloud administrator
first off you need experience with
programming languages like C sharpen.net
you'll also need to be experienced with
devops tools like Jenkins Docker ansible
and Chef you'll need to have an
understanding of database configuration
so that you can take advantage of all
the relevant information about the
hardware and software components used by
the organization you'll also need to
have experience with Cloud
infrastructure systems like servers
storage Network and visualization
software finally you'll also need to
configure virtual machines vpns and
Cloud servers now let's have a look at
the salary offered to Cloud
administrators now in the United States
the average salary of a cloud
administrator is approximately 65 000
per annum similarly in India it's
approximately 7 lakh rupees per annum
now let's have a look at some of the
companies hiring for cloud
administrators we have companies like
Wipro Infosys Accenture IBM and so on so
so here I see a comment which says I'm a
fresher and want to learn about AWS how
can I start so actually any fresher can
make a career in AWS as long as you have
interest towards the subject now if you
are from a non-technical background you
need to put in a lot more hard work and
have a lot of patience so I would
recommend that before you take up the
AWS course you have a look at the course
curriculum types of AWS courses
opportunities in the market for AWS
certified candidates and so on so now
let's go to number six Cloud application
developer now a cloud application
developer mainly focuses on implementing
and maintaining an organization's Cloud
infrastructure now they're involved with
designing building creating analyzing
and maintaining Cloud systems now these
individuals are also involved with
ensuring that there's an effective
design of business processes in the
cloud they're also involved with a
number of different tasks like
optimizing efficiency and performance
scaling application components and
security issues now let's have a look at
some of the skills required to become a
cloud application developer first off
you need to have experience with
database languages like MySQL SQL and
mongodb then you need to have experience
with programming languages like python
Ruby and Perl so that you can code and
create cloud computing applications
you'll also need to have experience with
Linux now this is because most Cloud
infrastructures are created with Linux
servers you'll also need to have
experience with cloud service providers
like Amazon web services Google Cloud
platform and Microsoft Azure you'll need
to have experience with information
security with the help of certifications
you'll also need to know how to create
microservices and to create Cloud
applications now let's have a look at
the salary offered to a cloud
application developer in the United
States it's approximately seventy
thousand dollars per annum in India the
average salary of a cloud application
developer is approximately 8 lakh rupees
per annum now let let's have a look at
some of the companies hiring Cloud
application developers you have
companies like Bosch McAfee sap and so
on so now let's go to number five Cloud
network engineer a cloud network
engineer is responsible for implementing
supporting maintaining and optimizing
the network Hardware software and
communication Links of the
organization's Cloud infrastructure he
or she basically focuses on Automation
and security while building the cloud
infrastructure enhancing Network tooling
visibility and improving productivity
now let's have a look at some of the
skills required to become a cloud
network engineer first off obviously you
need to have experience with networking
which means the familiarity with the
internet and Van communication
Technologies protocols and best
practices you need to have an
understanding of cloud security and how
you can design a public cloud with
multiple options you'll need to have an
experience with data center
Administration which basically means an
understanding on infrastructure design
operations and life cycle management and
finally you need to have experience with
cloud computing platforms like Amazon
web services Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform next let's have a look at
the salaries offered to a cloud network
engineer firstly the average salary for
cloud network engineer in the United
States is approximately 72 000 per annum
in India the average salary of a cloud
network engineer is approximately 4 lakh
rupees per annum now that we're done
with this let's have a look at the
company's hiring Cloud Network Engineers
we have companies like Amazon web
services Rakuten Cisco and so much more
now for number four we have Cloud
automation engineer a cloud automation
engineer focuses on cloud Automation
orchestration and integration he or she
implements optimizes and supports the
cloud infrastructure and ensures it has
high availability they also have to
increase the cost Effectiveness and
availability of the cloud now let's have
a look at some of the skills required to
become a cloud automation engineer first
off since the role is cloud-based
experience with the cloud service
platform like Microsoft Azure AWS or
Google Cloud platform is an absolute
must you'll also need to have experience
with programming languages like Python
and go that will help you make the
process of automation easier next
experience with devops tools like chef
ansible and public are seen as a huge
plus you'll also need to have an
understanding of Docker and containers
experience with databases like postgres
SQL and MySQL that can handle multiple
workloads would be very useful and
finally you need to have experience with
virtualization which means you need to
know how you can work with virtual
servers applications storage and
networks with this you can reduce the
amount of resources required by the
organization now let's have a look at
the salary offered to Cloud automation
engineers in the United States the
average salary for cloud automation
engineer is approximately 79 000 per
annum the average salary for cloud
automation engineer in India is
approximately 5 lakh rupees per annum
now that we're done let's have a look at
some of the companies hiring Cloud
automation Engineers we have companies
like Oracle Google Kappa Gemini Disney
and so on and now to number three
Cloud security manager a cloud security
manager is someone who's responsible for
providing security for cloud-based
digital platforms and protecting the
organization's data he or she may be
involved with creating new security
methods or to analyze existing ones they
may also have to create cloud-based
applications performing threat
simulations and providing security
recommendations now let's have a look at
some of the skills required to become a
cloud security manager first off you'll
need to have experience with at least
one of the popular cloud service
providers like Amazon web services
Microsoft Azure and gcp you'll also need
to have experience in programming
languages like python experience with
commonly used devops tools like Jenkin
so that you can Implement continuous
integration or continuous deployment
models would be very helpful you'll also
need to be well versed with TCP
protocols and other networking Concepts
you need to be well versed with pki SSL
SSH https and so on experience with
web-based Analytics and services would
also be very helpful now let's have a
look at the salary offered to a cloud
security manager in the United States
the average salary of a cloud security
manager is approximately 99 000 per
annum in India the average salary for
cloud security manager is approximately
11 lakh rupees per annum now let's have
a look at some of the companies hiring
Cloud security managers we have
companies like Deloitte VMware Cisco
Dell and so on now let's move on to
number two Cloud engineer a cloud
engineer is an individual who is
responsible for any technological duties
that are associated with cloud computing
including design planning management
maintenance and support they are also
involved with orchestrating and
automating cloud-based platforms
throughout the organization let's have a
look at the skills required to become a
cloud engineer first off you'll need to
have experience with at least one of the
popular cloud service providers like AWS
Microsoft Azure or the Google Cloud
platform you you'll need to have an
understanding of networking Concepts
like building and accessing servers
virtual networks and so on this enables
Cloud Engineers to make sure that the
network is responsive to the users next
you need to have experience with
virtualization with virtualization you
can reduce how many Hardware units you
need with the help of virtual machines
it also makes resources scalable and
fault tolerant in an organization
experience with the Linux operating
system would also be very helpful
considering how thirty percent of the
servers that powers your are Linux based
you'll need to know about apis to design
restful Services experience with devops
is also a major skill to have since
you'll be able to help handle work
dependencies between the development and
operation teams and finally you need to
have programming experience with
languages like Java python C plus and
Ruby next let's have a look at the
salary offered to a cloud engineer in
the United States the average salary of
a cloud engineer is approximately 100
five thousand dollars per annum the
average salary in India is approximately
five lakh rupees per annum now let's
have a look at some of the companies
hiring Cloud Engineers we have companies
like McAfee IBM JP Morgan visa and so on
now I see a pretty good question in the
chat how do you become a cloud engineer
so to become a cloud engineer you need
to have experience with the programming
language experience with at least one
cloud service platform which is Amazon
web services or Microsoft Azure or
Google Cloud platform the choice is
yours and you need to specialize in a
particular service be it storage
networking disaster recovery and so on
and now for number one Cloud architect a
cloud architect is responsible for
managing cloud computing architecture in
an organization he or she handles
everything to do with front-end
platforms servers storage delivery and
networks now let's have a look at some
of the skills required to become a cloud
architect first off you need to have
knowledge in programming knowledge about
Perl python Ruby PHP Java and net can
provide users with the ability to build
deploy and manage applications quickly
you'll need to know about the basics of
networking since most of the work what
you'll be doing would be web related
knowledge about networking can be really
helpful knowledge about data storage
fundamentals are also really important
this provides you with the knowledge to
determine which data storage option to
use and when being experienced with
cloud service platforms is also really
important platforms like AWS Google
Cloud platform and Microsoft Azure are
what you are going to be basing most of
your work on experience with them is
pretty important and finally Cloud
security this will help you make sure
that your data is secure and only
authorized code is run and the right
people are allowed to run it now let's
talk about the salary of a cloud
architect the average salary for cloud
architect is approximately 107 thousand
dollars per and in India the average
salary of a cloud architect is
approximately 16 lakh rupees per annum
and there you go those are the top job
roles in the field of cloud computing
now let's have a look at some of the
companies hiring Cloud Architects we
have companies like eyepro Huawei
Hewlett-Packard Enterprise and so on and
today I am going to tell you how you can
become a successful cloud computing
engineer now cloud computing is one of
those Technologies that's rapidly rising
and with any technology that's growing
rapidly it comes with several job
opportunities for the people who are
skilled in it so before we get into it
let's have a brief look at what is cloud
computing cloud computing refers to
services like storage databases software
analytics machine learning artificial
intelligence and so much more all of
which made accessible via the Internet
the cloud tech services Market is
expected to grow 17.3 percent in the
span of 2018 to 19 which means there's a
growth from
175.8 billion dollars to a whopping 206
billion dollars in 2019 and as of 2020
it's expected that 90 of all
organizations in the world would be
using cloud services not to mention
several organizations around the world
suggest that using Cloud Computing
Services has enabled their employees to
experiment a lot more with Technologies
like machine learning and artificial
intelligence so here's what we'll be
going through today firstly we'll be
talking about who is a cloud computing
engineer the steps you need to take to
become a cloud computing engineer and
the cloud computing engineer salaries so
first off who is a cloud computing
engineer now a cloud computing engineer
is an ID professional who takes care of
all the technical aspects of cloud
computing now be a design planning
maintenance and support now a cloud
computing engineer can take up a number
of different career paths this could be
that of a cloud developer security
engineer a full stack developer cisops
administrator Solutions architect Cloud
architect and so much more now let's
have a look at some of the major cloud
computing roles first off we have
Solutions architect now these are
individuals who are responsible for
analyzing the technical environment in
which they are going to produce the
solutions the requirements and the
specifications secondly they are
required to select an appropriate
technology that satisfies set
requirements they need to estimate and
manage the usage and the operational
costs of the solutions they provide and
they need to support project management
as well as solution development next we
have sysops administrators they are
involved in deploying managing and
operating highly scalable and fault
tolerant systems they need to select an
appropriate service based on compute
security or data requirements they need
to estimate and manage usage and
operational costs and they need to be
able to migrate on-premises workloads
onto an appropriate cloud computing
platform so among both of these roles
there are certain requirements that are
remaining constant now let's have a look
at the steps you need to take to become
a cloud computing engineer you the first
step is to gain Proficiency in a cloud
computing platform now the first step is
to become proficient in at least one of
the three major cloud computing
platforms be it AWS Azure or the Google
Cloud platform now there are a huge
number of resources that you can find on
the internet it could be YouTube videos
articles virtual or physical classrooms
and so much more now after you're done
learning you can get certified by
Microsoft Azure AWS or the Google Cloud
platform now for AWS you have a number
of different certifications which can be
divided into three categories which are
the foundational which is just the
basics the associate level
certifications the professional level
certifications and the specialty
certifications similarly with Microsoft
Azure you have certifications that
enable you to become an Azure developer
associate and as your administrator
associate and Azure architect
professional and a devops engineer now
most cloud computing platforms have a
free tier that you can take advantage of
these provide a number of free services
for period of time some of which are
free forever so you can use these
platforms to your advantage and do as
much practice as you can on them now if
you want to learn more about cloud
computing you can also check out Simply
learns YouTube channel then you can go
on to the playlist section right here
and you can find comprehensive videos on
a number of different cloud computing
platforms AWS and Microsoft Azure our
AWS tutorial videos talk about what
exactly is AWS how you can become an AWS
Solutions architect Amazon ec2 S3 some
of the other services and so much more
we also have detailed tutorials on Azure
which talks about what exactly is azure
the certifications provided by Azure
some of the services like machine
learning Azure active directory and so
much more and now we're at Step 2 being
experienced in at least one programming
language unlike general purpose
programming languages like C C plus plus
C sharp and so on cloud computing
requires ones that are a lot more data
oriented now out some of the major
programming languages that are used in
cloud computing are go python closure
and Java now as I said before there is a
wealth of resources that you can learn
from there are free websites that you
can practice your code on like quick
code code academy and several others
there's also resources like YouTube
videos as well as that's the option of
online or offline classes now we're at
step 3 specialization you'll also need
to be well versed with a number of key
Concepts these are storage and
networking now with storage you need to
know how data can be stored and where it
can be accessed from you need to know
how it can be accessed from multiple
different resources you'll also need to
have some experience with the services
provided by Azure and AWS like the
Amazon S3 in AWS and the appropriately
named Azure storage from Microsoft Azure
with networking you need to have a
strong understanding of the networking
fundamentals as well as virtual networks
next up we have virtualization and
operating systems with virtualization
you need to know how virtual networks
which are just a combination of
different virtual machines can be used
to emulate different components in a
particular system with operating systems
you need to have a very strong
understanding operating systems like
Windows and Linux next up we have
security and Disaster Recovery now you
need to understand how data application
as well as infrastructure can be
protected from malicious attacks With
Disaster Recovery you need to be
prepared for any unexpected circumstance
by making sure your systems are always
safe and are regularly backed up to
prevent any sort of loss of data then we
have web services and devops now you
need to have a strong understanding of
apis or application program interfaces
and web services some amount of
experience with web design also can be
of great help with devops you need to
have a strong understanding of how cloud
computing is able to provide a
centralized platform on which you can
perform testing deployment and
production for develop automation
moreover with devops you understand the
Synergy that the operations as well as
the development teams have with each
other and for the success of any project
and finally your cloud computing
engineer now let's have a look at the
salaries of cloud computing engineers in
the United States cloud computing
Engineers earn around 116 000 dollars
per annum in India a cloud computing
engineer is paid approximately 6 lakhs
66 000 rupees per annum now how can
simply learn help you become a cloud
computing engineer so let's head on to
simplyon's website here we have the
cloud architect Masters program now this
deals with a number of different courses
all of which that can help you get
started in your journey to becoming a
cloud computing engineer this master's
program covers a number of different
courses like AWS technical Essentials
Microsoft Azure fundamentals AWS
developer associate and so much more it
provides you 40 plus in-demand skills
and 25 plus Services provides you a
master certification it has 16 plus rate
life projects and helps you get a salary
that ranges between 15 to 25 lakh rupees
per annum it also covers a variety of
tools like Amazon ec2 Azure data Factory
virtual machines and so much more so why
don't you head on to simplylearn.com and
get started on your journey to getting
certified and getting ahead here we wrap
up with the cloud computing Basics if
you like this video then hit the like
button consider subscribing to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply loot till
then keep watching and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here